Hallo, ich bin auch wieder da.
Heute müssen wir tatsächlich mal was Sinnvolles machen.
Wir müssen nämlich einen ordentlichen neuen Handyvertrag raussuchen.
Das heißt, wir müssen ein paar Anbieter vergleichen.
Ich vermute mal, dass alle anderen Anbieter, außer so die großen drei, eh wegfallen werden.
Aber, ja, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Du hattest recht, es gibt anonymen Twitch-IRC-Login.
Hat mich nur Monate gekostet.
Wie, warum hat dich das Monate gekostet?
Hä?
Den Zusammenhang verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau, weil, unabhängig davon, ob es das gibt oder nicht.
Ich habe ja sogar in einem Video schon mal gezeigt, wie man das, also in einem Video, in einem Stream schon mal gezeigt, wie man das benutzt.
Also insofern, hä?
Moin, Leute.
Pogu.
Pogu, Poguas, Pogu.
Ne, was auch immer.
Ich muss euch übrigens noch was zeigen.
Ich habe was entdeckt.
Auf Reddit.
Ja.
Das habe ich auch bei mir im Stream damals gezeigt, dass man das machen muss.
Das habe ich auch nicht gecheckt erst.
Justin-Fan muss man nehmen.
Ja, genau.
Genau, ich erinnere mich.
Justin-Fan.
Und dann kriegst du aber alle Nachrichten IRC-mäßig mit Newline terminiert oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, wir haben es, wir haben es, wir haben das schon, wir haben uns das, wie gesagt, wir haben uns das angeguckt.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, IRC.
Half IRC?
Ne, was?
DHL-GP.
Baited?
Äh, wieder Zeit für Streams.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wo das, wo das ist.
Twitch-Chat?
Okay, ne, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht mal, wie das, wie das hieß.
Ach, du hast es gefunden.
Ne, wie gesagt, ich wüsste jetzt den Titel auch gerade nicht mehr.
Ja.
Ja, also Leute, ich wollte euch was zeigen, genau.
Und zwar, hups.
Ne, nochmal starten geht nicht.
Das ist dafür nicht ausgelegt.
Das ist, das ist zu kaputt.
Dieses Image-Overlating, das kann man nicht mehrfach starten.
Das klappt nicht.
Wenn man das versucht mehrfach zu starten, dann...
Ripp.
Ich habe was gefunden auf Reddit.
Irgendwo auf, ich glaube, ich glaube auf dem self-hosted Reddit oder so.
Wir hatten es doch letztens davon, wie man oder wo man eine kostenlose VM bekommen kann, bei welchen Cloud-Anbietern.
Und das haben ja die meisten Cloud-Anbieter in FreeTier.
Aber so wirklich...
Ne, ne VM, die man quasi 24-7 laufen lassen kann, benutzen kann und nix bezahlen muss, gibt es nicht so oft.
Ich habe ja damals gezeigt, dass Oracle-VM, genau, äh, nicht Oracle-VM, Oracle, äh, die Oracle Cloud hat sowas, FreeTier.
Ein relativ großzügiges FreeTier.
Ich vermute allerdings, ich habe jetzt aber noch was anderes gefunden, zeige ich euch gleich.
Ähm, ein relativ großzügiges FreeTier hatten die.
Nämlich, du bekommst sogar, sogar zwei VMs mittlerweile.
Okay, das ist neu.
Da war das letzte Mal nicht noch eine.
Nein, du bekommst sogar zwei, zwei VMs kannst du bekommen.
Äh, mit 1 GB RAM, was relativ großzügig ist.
Und irgendwie gesharter, gesharter CPU.
Oder du kannst auch noch irgendwie eine ARM-basierte VM machen.
Also das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht für kostenlos.
Aber ich habe noch was anderes gefunden.
Was auf den ersten Blick nicht unbedingt besser aussieht, aber anders.
Und zwar habe ich das auf Reddit, ich glaube im self-hosted Subreddit gefunden.
Fly.io kannte ich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Gar nicht.
Ich habe da mal auf YouTube geguckt und habe festgestellt, so unbekannt scheint der Service gar nicht zu sein.
Ich kannte ihn bis dahin nicht.
Und die haben, wenn man mal Pricing guckt.
Wenn man mal Pricing guckt, haben die auch, ähm, zwar nur 100, 100, ähm, äh, einmal 256 MB VM.
Aber, du kannst auch bis zu drei Total VMs machen.
Jetzt auch nicht.
Das ist nicht so schlecht mit dem Free-Tier.
Bei Oracle muss man die Kreditkarte hinterlegen.
Das probieren wir doch jetzt mal aus, Leute.
Das testen, okay, bevor das Schreiben richtig losgeht, das testen wir mal.
Ich habe das noch nicht ausprobiert.
Need an Account, ja, ja, 10-Minute-Mail.
Ja, perfekt, perfekt, E-Mail.
Genau die, Brauma Preferred Name.
Kekkel Omega 0.
Äh, ich stecke mir mal schnell ein Passwort aus.
Irgendein Passwort, was die hoffentlich fressen werden.
So, sehr gut.
Create my Account.
Ah, Add a Payment Method.
Hehehe.
Ja, for free.
Ich will es for free tryen.
Okay, man muss es doch nicht enden.
Me, MeGrePatron48, freust du dich schon auf Dienstag, wenn Battlefield 20 auf YouTube PS5 gratis wird?
Ja, ein bisschen, vielleicht.
Äh, hat denn die PayPal?
Hobbyplan for free.
Get started with our free tier.
Man braucht keine Kreditkarte.
Keine Kreditkarte anscheinend, okay.
Und man muss, und man muss auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen die, die E-Mail-Adresse nicht bestätigen.
Das ist schon mal ein bisschen, bisschen Massive, Massive Debate.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie es jetzt weiter funktioniert.
Warte, warte, das wird, äh, Moment, PS5.
Ne, Moment, auf der PS5 ist es doch nicht gratis.
Ich dachte, das ist Teil von irgendeinem, von irgendeinem Playstation Plus Pass oder sowas.
Ja, genau.
Es wird Dienstag gratis, wirklich?
Ach.
Ach, nur, nur Dienstag oder sowas.
Also, nur, nur Dienstag ist mal.
Ne, kommt zu PlayStation Plus.
Ne, das wird nicht gratis in dem Sinn.
PlayStation Plus muss ja trotzdem, aber PlayStation Plus muss ja trotzdem bezahlen.
So, und jetzt kann man hier was auch immer machen.
Jetzt habe ich keine Ahnung, was man jetzt hier, hier machen kann, aber man kann angeblich jetzt hier eine VM erstellen.
Und die benutzen.
Let's go.
Äh, Launch Web CLI?
Äh.
Okay.
Ich bin, ich bin jetzt, äh, sehr planlos.
Und jetzt, wie lege ich jetzt eine VM an?
Ich habe das nur vorhin auf Reddit gefunden und ich sagte mir, ich zeige es euch mal kurz.
Aber das ist ja wieder absoluter Five Head Shit.
Hier, Machines.
Ich will eine Linux-Machine haben.
Ah, das sind Firecracker-VMs.
Äh, Firecracker, das ist so eine Virtualisierungsplattform von, ich glaube, Amazon?
War das Amazon?
So minimal KVM-VMs sind das.
So.
Ähm, Random-Machine-App.
Okay, Leute, ich habe jetzt seriously keinen Plan, wie das funktioniert.
Wie auch immer.
Curl?
Assume.
Random-Machine-Using-Fly-CTL.
Deploy?
Apps create?
Okay, ich habe keinen Plan.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Das, das, das sieht jetzt eher nicht nach vollständigen VMs aus, sondern eher nach irgendwelchen Containern, wobei es ja Firecracker-VMs sind.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das muss ich mir im Detail angucken.
Man kann, man kann mit Terraform das Ganze wohl auch verwalten.
Aber so, aber so eine VM, wo man sich dann einfach einloggen kann und Zeug drauf installieren kann und so ist ja nicht.
Das, das gucke ich mir, das gucke ich mir mal bei Gelegenheit an.
Da will jetzt auch nichts leaken oder sonst was.
Ja.
Also, keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Zumindest haben die ein Free Tier.
Was war das?
Fly?
Fly-CTL.
Okay, Fly-CTL.
Machines.
Und jetzt Run.
Help.
Is this what you want?
Yes.
Okay.
Verify your email address.
Alles klar, mache ich.
Kein Problem.
Verify email address.
Wann machen wir Kubernetes-Stells im Stream?
Bald, bald, Leute.
Machen wir bald.
Machines.
No Machines.
Das ist extrem.
Six-Head-Time.
Wie auch immer das funktioniert.
Ich wollte es euch eigentlich nur kurz zeigen.
Das ist nicht ewig.
Okay, Help.
Yes.
Ha!
You need payment information to continue.
Hehe.
Yep, cock.
Ich wusste es doch.
Okay, auch da nur mit Kreditkarte.
G-Bated.
Ja.
Massive.
G-Bated.
Ich hab schon gedacht, man kann das Ganze ohne Kreditkarte.
Nope.
Moin, kennst du?
Disposable Root-Servers.
Ne, was ist das?
Hackers Choice.
Login.
Zagfold offers free unlimited Root-Servers.
A new server inside.
It's created for every...
Ach, für jede SSH-Connection.
Ne.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nur, wenn man kurz, wenn man mal was
kurz braucht, so nach dem Motto, ich brauche einen Server, wo ich 24-7 was drauflaufen
lasse, ist nicht so sinnig.
Okay, kenn ich nicht, ist aber interessant.
Wusste ich nicht, dass es das gibt, wenn man mal kurz, wenn man mal ganz kurz eine Linux-Kiste,
eine anonyme Linux-Kiste für irgendwas braucht oder eine halbwegs anonyme Linux-Kiste für
irgendwas braucht.
Ist gar nicht so, gar nicht verkehrt.
Das stimmt wohl, dass, das gucken wir uns heute an, wie das ist mit äh, mit Verträgen,
weil ich brauche einen neuen Vertrag und warum brauche ich einen neuen Vertrag?
Ganz einfach, kann ich euch an der Stelle mal kurz erzählen, ich bin noch zwei Wochen
bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber, okay, man ist eigentlich immer beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
da wo ich schon jetzt über 10 Jahre bin, bin ich ja nur noch zwei Wochen.
Ab 1.
April geht's äh, bei einem anderen Laden los und ich hab aktuell noch das Handy von
der Firma, was, also ich hab hier den iPhone, was ist das, iPhone 11, glaub ich?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das erkennt.
Wie sieht denn ein iPhone 11 von hinten aus?
Das hat nur zwei Kameras.
iPhone 11, boah, hier, so, ja, das, das sieht, sieht richtig aus, ja, so sieht das von hinten
aus.
Also ein iPhone 11, so und das hab ich hier noch im Einsatz von denen.
Ich hab mir jetzt ein iPhone 14 gekauft, das liegt hier rum und theoretisch hab, hatte
ich dafür auch eine Hülle bestellt, Moment, ich muss mal kurz bei Amazon gucken, wo die,
wo die bleibt.
Sekunde.
Your orders.
iPhone Case.
Ne, das kam angeblich wohl an, ich weiß nicht, wo ich's hingeschmissen hab, muss ich
mal gucken.
Irgendwo hab ich's, irgendwo in die Ecke werde ich's gepfeffert haben, also es ist wohl schon
angekommen.
Na gut.
Ja.
Okay, das, das muss ich mir gleich mal angucken.
Zumindest, äh, danke Leute für die ganzen Subs hier.
Schlechtes WLAN, sehr gute Subscription, exzellent, du brauchst einen gescheiten Accesspoint, hab
ich auch in einem der letzten Streams noch was gescheites gezeigt, gibt's, äh, es gibt
sehr gute Accesspoints, die man sich kaufen kann bei Ebay.
Die besser sind als iPhone 11.
Die besser sind als, also auch von Features her, als die meisten, äh, anderen Dinger,
die die Leute so am Start haben.
Ja, also, wie gesagt, ich hab aktuell ein Handy von der Firma gestellt.
Brauchst du denn mobile Daten?
Ja, so ungefähr 20G.
Jetzt können wir uns, können wir uns gleich mal aufschreiben, was ich haben will.
Ich kann, ich kann nichts erzählen.
Also ich will ungefähr 20G, hab ich so mal über den Daumen gepackt, ungefähr 20G brauch
ich im Monat.
Bin ja schon ab und zu mal unterwegs, sei es jetzt, weil ich doch mal ins Büro fahr,
oder weil ich im Zug sitze eine Weile und die Bahn zu spät ist und ich dann YouTube
Videos gucke und sonst was, ja, also ungefähr 20G.
Zumindest, ich hab aktuell ein iPhone 11 von der Firma gestellt und ich wechsel ja allerdings
das Unternehmen zum ersten April, beziehungsweise zum dreißigsten, dritten oder einunddreißigsten,
wie, Moment, wie viele Tage hat eigentlich der März?
Einunddreißig, ja, hier, hier, hier wechsel ich dann, nee, hier kann ich schlecht wechseln,
ich wechsel da.
Dritter April, okay, so, und, ja, mach ich, mach ich gleich alles.
Ich, ich guck mir gleich mein Handyanbieter an und das muss ich abgeben.
Was ich machen kann ist, weil ich ja schon so lang da bin und ich auch die Handynummer
für Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung benutze und viele Leute auch diese Handynummer, die
einzige Handynummer ist, die sie von mir haben, also das von der Firma gestellte Handy mit
dem von der Firma gestellten Vertrag, haben die gesagt, ich kann meine Rufnummer übernehmen.
Also ich kann meine Rufnummer portieren lassen, wenn ich das will.
Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt einen Vertrag, ein neues Handy habe ich schon, ich brauche
jetzt einen Vertrag, wo ich das hinportieren lassen kann, dass ich das die nächsten zwei
Wochen noch machen, machen kann, weil ich bin bloß noch zwei Wochen auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin zwar offiziell erst am einunddreißigsten weg, allerdings bin ich schon, Moment, allerdings
bin ich ja schon, weil ich noch sechs Tage Resturlaub habe.
Und noch 15 Stunden.
Und noch 15 Stunden auf meinem Rufbereitschaftskonto bin ich ja schon weg am 1, 2, 3, 4, hier arbeite
ich eh nicht montags, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, also eigentlich da schon, weil 15 Stunden sind
ja zwei Tage.
Eigentlich könnte ich theoretisch am 17. schon weg sein.
So, das ist glaube ich noch besser, dann habe ich nämlich einfach nochmal zwei Wochen
Urlaub.
Zwischendurch.
Das war schon mal, das ist schon mal extrem nice.
Also hier, entweder, entweder bin ich schon, entweder bin ich 17.
weg oder spätestens 22.
Also entweder ist der 17.
der letzte Tag oder 22.
ist der letzte Tag.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt noch nächste Woche Zeit, übernächste Woche Zeit, einen neuen
Vertrag abzuschließen und meine Rufnummer portieren zu lassen, dass ich die behalten
kann.
So.
Und deswegen brauche ich einen neuen Handytarif.
Ganz einfach.
Ich musste eine Fritzbox als Accesspoint umbauen, weil Kupferleitungen in der Wand abgestorben
sind.
Sterben dann Kupferleitungen in der Wand ab?
Nee, Internet und Mobilfunk will ich nicht vom gleichen, also brauche ich nicht vom gleichen
Anbieter.
Ich meine, ich könnte es machen, weil ich bei Vodafone bin, aber nee, ich will das unabhängig
voneinander haben, dass ich das alles, je nachdem wie ich will, schnell wechseln kann
und mir nicht um tausend Sachen Gedanken machen muss.
Sim.de klingt nach irgendeinem Scam.
Aber nee, anscheinend nicht.
Ja, Vodafone hat auch Probleme, aber da kann das WLAN ja gut sein, aber dein Provider trotzdem
scheiße bauen.
Ja, ich habe auch öfters Probleme mit Vodafone.
Okay, Telekom gucken wir auch gleich.
Warum?
Sind die anderen so kacke von der Abdeckung her oder wie ist das so?
Weil Telekom ist, glaube ich, auch mit Abstand das teuerste.
SMS-Flat brauche ich nicht.
Ja.
Windows-Logik muss man nicht versuchen zu durchschauen.
Ah.
Aha.
Hier ist kaum O2 oder Vodafone.
Wieso?
Was sagst du gegen O2?
Wie gesagt, interessiert mich, weil ich will jetzt ja nicht zu irgendeinem Kack-Anbieter
gehen.
Wobei letztendlich wahrscheinlich unterm Strich sind alle irgendwie kacke.
Also mein Nutzungsverhalten ist relativ einfach zu beschreiben.
Ich brauche ungefähr 20 Gigabyte, also 10 bis 20 Gigabyte oder sagen wir mal so.
Wenn ich total übertreibe, 10 bis 30 Gigabyte.
Aber 20, 20 ist, 20 ist, denke ich, ist, denke ich, ganz, ganz, ganz guter Guess.
Ja.
Handyvertrag.de.
Jetzt geht's aber los.
Beste, beste Internetseiten hier von der, von der URL.
Also dann, was ich, was ich haben, was ich gerne haben würde, ist die Möglichkeit,
ähm, eSIM.
Und nach Möglichkeit.
Ja.
Nach Möglichkeit auch Multisim, weil ich kann euch das auch erklären, warum ich nehme
mir meine Rufnummer mit jetzt zu einem eigenen Vertrag und ich habe ein eigenes iPhone, aber
es kann ja durchaus sein, dass ich wieder ein Handy gestellt bekomme vom neuen Arbeitgeber.
Was heißt das?
Kann so sein.
Das wird so sein.
Ich weiß, dass das so ist.
Und das hat dann wahrscheinlich auch mal eine neue, eine neue, neue Nummer oder so.
Mal gucken.
Die können mich auch wie auch immer da eintragen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie ihre Apps vorinstalliert haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Also wahrscheinlich kriege ich ein eigenes Handy.
Und das kann man aber auch privat benutzen, das eigene Handy, äh, das, das vom Arbeitgeber,
das Handy.
So.
Und ich habe mir überlegt, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt, ich habe ja schon ein eigenes iPhone
gekauft, dann könnte ich einfach dort eine zweite SIM reinmachen, entweder als SIM oder
als eSIM.
Und dann habe ich einfach schlicht ergreifend zwei Geräte.
Das eine kann ich quasi beruflich und privat benutzen mit der gleichen, mit der gleichen
Nummer.
Und das andere ist halt mein privates Handy, was ich überall hin mitnehme.
Ja.
Das heißt, die Sache, mehrere SIM-Karten für den gleich, für die gleiche Nummer wäre
in dem Fall, denke ich mal, schon sehr praktisch.
Und die Variante als eSIM natürlich auch, dass man nicht mehr mit SIM-Karten rumhantieren
muss und dass man im Zweifelsfall, je nachdem, was die haben, dann es jeweils andere benutzen
kann.
Ja, dann einfach Telekom bestellen, da geht alles.
Das habe ich auch schon mitgekriegt.
Allerdings ist die Telekom auch mit Abstand am teuersten.
Mal gucken, was es so, was es sonst noch so gibt.
So.
Die Seite klingt, die Seite klingt übrigens übelst skamast.
Wenn ich das schon sehe, Handyvertrag.de, Mann.
Es sieht, es sieht irgendwie schon ein bisschen, weiß nicht.
LTE, ah, das ist nur LTE, mie.
Kein 5G.
Warum?
Warum nicht?
Das funktioniert nicht.
Also.
Also müsste sich das dazu ja zeitlich irgendwie ein bisschen überschneiden, was es nicht
macht.
Und die werden mir sicherlich eine neue Nummer und neues Handy geben.
5G voll sinnlos.
Naja, Moment.
5G ist nicht sinnvoll von der Geschwindigkeit allein, sondern bestimmt in Zukunft auch für
die Abdeckung.
Und wenn du einen Vertrag hast, die nur oder meinen die damit nicht 5G Connectivity, sondern
LTE oder Geschwindigkeit.
Weil wenn jetzt beispielsweise hier.
Hier steht jetzt ja.
Ähm.
10G LTE.
Heißt das dann auch, ich kann mich nicht zu 5G Masten connecten oder heißt das die Geschwindigkeit
des LTE?
5G Abdecken.
Naja, man muss jetzt ja nicht unbedingt von jetzt aktuellem Iststand ausgehen, sondern
vielleicht auch mal zwei, drei Jahre in die Zukunft.
Also jetzt irgendwie was noch kaufen, wo ich keinen Zugang zu 5G Sachen bekomme, ist doch
auch doof, oder?
Was soll der Vertrag können?
Also bis jetzt.
Bis jetzt habe ich nur für mich festgestellt, dass ich ungefähr 20 GB brauche im Monat.
Also weniger geht auch, aber mit 20 G bin ich auf jeden Fall auf der sicheren Seite.
Möglichkeit für eSIM und mindestens zwei SIM Karten, wenn auch praktisch.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich will mit denen ehrlich gesagt auch dann das nicht so nicht so sehr da verbandeln.
Also das einzige, was ich Mobilfunk technisch die letzten Jahre über zu tun hat, ist tatsächlich.
Aldi Talk.
Da habe ich meiner Mutter nämlich einen Prepaid Vertrag gekauft bei Aldi Talk.
Sowas habe ich.
Der sowas irgendwie Kombi Paket S habe ich sehr wenig, wobei doch kann kann tatsächlich
sein.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, irgendwie sowas habe ich der gekauft, die benutzt, die benutzt
das Handy im Endeffekt so gut wie gar nicht.
Und wenn überhaupt, dann guckt die da irgendwie einmal in der Woche kurz was nach im Internet.
Und das war's.
Und nimmt hauptsächlich.
Ja.
Ein paar Gespräche an, wenn überhaupt.
Also das hatte das natürlich sehr günstig, wobei für mich das Ganze nicht reicht.
Drei Gigabyte ist definitiv zu wenig.
Damit komme ich auf gar keinen Fall hin.
12 G, wäre wäre das Minimum.
Also 12 G wäre wirklich das Minimum, was ich, was ich nehmen würde.
Der Rest ist mir der Rest ist mir ein bisschen zu zu wenig.
Also das.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das spricht mich jetzt nicht an.
Komm, wir gucken mal.
Komm, wir gucken mal. Welche? Wir können das doch ganz einfach einschränken.
Die haben doch bestimmt auch keine Möglichkeit, eSIM, Multisim oder sonstige Geschichten.
Also, wir gucken mal. Welche Anbieter haben Multisim-Anbieter?
Da gibt es doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele.
Und dementsprechend können wir das doch schon eingrenzen, was da sinnvoll ist und was nicht.
Okay. Kongstar. Aber Kongstar hat keine mehreren SIM-Karten, oder?
Ich will auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit haben, mehrere SIM-Karten zu haben. Für die gleiche Nummer.
Kongstar hat Multisim? Wirklich?
Kongstar hat Multisim. Die Multisim bei Kongstar.
Haben die eSIM? Ach ja, tatsächlich.
Deinen Vertrag jetzt auf zwei Geräten nutzen. Neu bei Kongstar.
Multisim. Okay, interessant.
Okay, hier. Die Computer, Computerbild weiß Bescheid.
Was darf es kosten? Das habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken zugemacht.
Ich gucke einfach mal, was es denn so normalerweise kostet.
Wenn, wenn ich was haben will mit 20G und mehreren SIM-Karten und dann mal gucken, was das beste Preis-Leistung hat.
Das heißt, du bezahlst, das heißt, du bezahlst 50 Euro im Monat fürs Handy, Paul.
Das erscheint mir jetzt doch relativ viel.
Okay, lass mal kurz.
Lass mal kurz checken, also.
Einloggen und bestellen. Deine Multisim verwalten.
Nutze mit der flexiblen Multisim-Option deinen Vertrag auf mehreren Geräten gleichzeitig mit einem Vertrag, einer und einer einzigen Rechnung.
Wow.
Okay, ein Vertrag, eine Rufnummer, eine Rechnung.
Ah.
Siehste? Das ist schon mal doof.
Ich hätte gerne die Möglichkeit, das auch als eSIM zu machen.
Gut, ich meine, das wäre jetzt nicht so wild.
Das wäre jetzt nicht so wild.
So.
Solange ich, solange ich eine von beiden Karten, also eine von beiden Karten als eSIM machen kann.
Kongster, kann, kann Kongster eSIM?
Da blicke ich wieder nicht durch, wie was, wie wo geht.
Tarife mit eSIM.
Okay, dann geht das aber mit Multisim nicht zusammen, anscheinend.
Das, das verwirrt mich jetzt schon wieder.
Lass mal kurz, mal kurz gucken, was, was kostet denn bei denen zumindest irgendwie was halbwegs, halbwegs passendes.
Schon mal wieder so aufgebaut.
So aufgebaut, dass ich überhaupt nicht weiß, was die mir sagen wollen.
Die Telekom, die, dass die Telekom das kann, weiß ich.
Die Telekom kann so gut wie alles, allerdings, ähm, auch die teuersten, ja.
So, wähle deine Allnet-Flat.
Ich brauche keine Allnet-Flat.
Ich telefoniere so gut wie gar nicht über Mobilfunk mit meinem Handy.
Aber wahrscheinlich musst du hier irgendwie, das ist Datenvolumen, okay.
Ganz schön.
Da ist es ja sogar bei der Telekom fast noch billiger.
Wie sieht das denn überhaupt aus?
Wie sieht das überhaupt bei dir zwecks Netz aus?
Wie soll es bei mir aussehen, zwecks Netz?
Wie jetzt?
Was, was da besonders ausgebaut ist bei mir in der Ecke?
Ich wohne Frankfurt, äh, ich wohne in Frankfurt, beziehungsweise in der Nähe von Frankfurt.
Ich glaube, hier ist alles ganz gut, ganz gut, äh, ausgebaut.
Das Einzige, wo ich jeden Tag Probleme habe, also jeden Tag, wo ich im Zug fahre, ist in Maintal am Bahnhof, wo ich irgendwie keinen Empfang habe für mal kurz, kurze Zeit.
Wenn du jung bist, oh too young, da bin ich nicht jung genug für.
Oh too hat auch was ab 60 plus, aber so alt bin ich auch noch nicht.
Okay, also, also ich glaube, 8 Gigabyte ist mir ein bisschen wenig, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
So 18, 18 wäre, denke ich, ganz gut.
Komm, wir gucken, wir gucken jetzt mal so als, wir gucken mal so als, äh, Base-Geschichte bei der Telekom, was es da kosten wird.
Smartphone-Tarife.
Einfach, dass wir mal wissen, was so das Teuerste ist.
Was es so gibt.
So, also, ich brauche nur eine Sim, äh, ne, Moment.
Wie viele Karten?
Moment, ich möchte einen Vertrag mit mehreren Karten.
Das ist aber was, was anderes hier.
Mobilfunk in Deutschland, ja.
Okay, Leute, 5 Gigabyte wollen die ernsthaft schon 35 Euro.
Und dann Tarife ohne Laufzeit, ja.
Ist das mit, das ist nicht mit Handy, oder?
Ne, ne.
Okay, Gerät hinzufügen kann man auch machen, aber 75 Euro im Monat.
Also ganz im Ernst, irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
Das ist, Leute, 50 Euro im Monat, wenn ich 20G haben will.
Das ist schon on, plus, jetzt haltet euch mal fest, da kommen ja noch 5 Euro obendrauf,
weil ich, weil ich 2 Sim-Karten habe.
Also, da muss man bei Czach24, das machen wir jetzt, Czach24, sehr, sehr gut hier, exzellent.
Machen wir jetzt, wir vergleichen das jetzt, aber Achtung, Flashbang-Time, Leute.
Boah, Czach24, boah, da, aber das ist ja abartig teuer.
Ich meine, und einmalig nochmal 40 Euro, üben drauf.
50 Euro unlimited, aber 50 Euro, aber unlimited kostet, kostet nur 85.
Du hast es wahrscheinlich mal abgeschlossen
Irgendwann vor 10 Jahren oder so
15 Euro Rabattcode
Das heißt
Dann habe ich ungefähr die Kosten von der zweiten Simkarte
Wieder drin
Also pass mal auf
Tarif auswählen
Und jetzt noch eine zweite Simkarte dabei
Was
Was wollen die von mir
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung was das Popup mir sagen soll
Jetzt
Ich will das nicht
Ich will eine Multisim
Ah Moment ich habe das falsche angeklickt
Ich habe Multisim gelesen
Aber das hier angeklickt
Okay das ist natürlich Fail
Das hier wollte ich eigentlich anklicken
Brauche ich alles nicht
Internationale SMS
Ja klar weil ich auch noch so viele SMS verschicke
So in den Warenkorb
Und am Ende kostet es jetzt
Alter ist das teuer man
Guckt euch das mal an
55 Euro
Und als würde es noch nicht reichen
Nochmal 40 Euro einmalig
Es ist doch nicht teuer genug
Dass es 55 Euro im Monat kostet
Warum ist es auf einmal Triple Sim
Ich will doch nur eine zweite haben
Aber immerhin keine Versand
Da habe ich nochmal Glück gehabt
Dass es keine Versandkosten hat hier
Du hast die Laufzeit weg gemacht
Ja das ist auch Absicht
Winsim
Oh ne
Die skippe ich
Passt mal auf
Da gehe ich nicht hin
Ich weiß die anderen haben auch keine wirklich besseren Bewertungen
Aber bei den anderen ist es so
Dass nicht nur das reine Mobilfunkzeug bewertet wird
Sondern immer auch alles
Also wenn du hier zum Beispiel bei der Telekom guckst
Dann
Sind die auch scheiße bewertet
Aber das ist halt das komplette Telekom Laden
Und hier weißt du es ist mehr oder weniger
Was
Okay
Die Bewertung klingt schon äußerst pepega
Datenverlust nach zwei Tagen trotz Wlan
Hä
Was will er mir sagen
Okay
Am zweiten Tag des neuen Monats
War das Datenvolumen angeblich plötzlich aufgebraut
Obwohl zu Hause in Funktion ohne viele Minuten zu sein
Ach so meint er das
Ach so
Brauchst sonst mal Daten innerhalb der ganzen Monat
Anwendungsfehler auch in dem Chat
Ne es kann ja auch sein
Es ist doch durchaus möglich
Dass er es wirklich verkackt hat
Also dass er beispielsweise
Youtube über Nacht laufen hatte über Wlan und sowas
Wo gibt es eine Karte
Mobilfunkabdeckung Deutschland
Logitech
Anbieter
Okay das ist gut
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an
Was ist das
Was zum
Gibt es da irgendwie
Moment
Gibt es da irgendwie so ein Vergleichs
Vergleichskarte oder
Freenet ist doch alles das alles aus
Freenet ist doch das was früher mal E plus
Mitgemacht hat oder
Also auch quasi O2
Jetzt oder es war es
Nicht so dass es nicht nur drei Anbieter gibt
Es gibt
Es gibt die Telekom
Es gibt Vodafone ist das was früher mal Mannesmann
Oder so gewesen ist
Und dann gibt es glaub noch Telefonica
Oder warte mal das stand doch das stand doch irgendwie
Also das ist O2 und sowas
Mobilfunkmonitoring
Auf gehts
Ups jetzt habe ich irgendein Mistcopy
Pasted
Gigabitgrundbuch
Die haben immer
Die abgedrehtesten Benamungen
Für ihr Zeug Mann
Gigabitgrundbuchbund.de
Die
Denken sich da immer Dinge aus
Man muss den ja schon eins zugute halten
Also im Ausdenken von solchen komischen Wörtern
Sind die wirklich geil
Mobilfunkmonitoringkarte
Ach so
Das Gigabitgrundbuch das kenn ich sogar
Das habe ich in einem meiner Videos mal erwähnt
Das ist was was im Zuge der
Gigabitstrategie
Der deutschen Gigabitstrategie
Eingeführt werden soll
Das man nachvollziehen kann
Wie gut das ganze vorwärts geht
Das habe ich sogar mal
In einem Video erwähnt finde ich an sich eine sinnvolle Geschichte
Das dumme ist nur dass die glaub ich wieder
Mobilfunk dabei zählen
Und Mobilfunk ist
Das ist eine wichtige Geschichte, aber es ersetzt kein Gigabit-Glasfaseranschluss daheim.
Telekom gleich die 1, Vodafone gleich die 2 und dann noch O2, E+.
Ja, genau, so habe ich das auch im Hinterkopf.
Okay, zeig her.
Mit was haben die das gemacht?
Das müssen wir uns gleich mal kurz angucken.
Das ist Mapbox?
Ne, das ist nicht Mapbox.
Mapbox ist das viel zu hässlich.
Was benutzen die denn?
Lasst mal kurz gucken.
Mapserver.
Oh, irgendwas eigenes.
Argus, das kenne ich, das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Build Interactive Webmasters with Argus Online.
Okay, das da.
Was verwenden die wohl für Maps?
Alter, wie viel laden die denn da bitte schön runter?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Bootstrap?
Webfonds?
Okay.
Ich würde...
Sag mal, Chat.
Bin ich zu blöd?
Kann man nicht normalerweise das hier...
Kann man das nicht normalerweise runter machen?
Und dann stehen die...
Dann stehen die URLs da?
So?
Ah, ne.
Ah, ne, passt doch.
Ne, Moment.
Hä?
Das sieht irgendwie komisch aus.
So habe ich das nicht in Erinnerung.
Das habe ich gemeint.
So sieht das normalerweise aus.
Ja, okay.
Okay, ist auch egal, was die verwenden.
Additional Kacheln.css.
Ja, da weißt du Bescheid.
Okay, guck mal mal.
Oder guck mal, Hanau.
Ja, da weiß man aber nicht, welche...
Moment, da kann man nach Anbieter filtern.
Ne, gell?
Hier?
Ah.
Ah, so.
Okay, lass mal gucken.
Wie ist es denn in Hanau so?
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Wir vergleichen mal zwei Sachen.
Einmal Hanau und dann zwei Ecken, wo ich...
Oder eine Ecke, wo ich ganz gerne wandern gehe.
Das ist so ein bisschen außerhalb.
5G, DSS, 5G.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Huge League, ja.
So, also.
Okay, Vodafone hat hier 5G, DSS.
Telekom hat hier 5G.
Was habe ich denn aktuell gerade?
Zeig mal.
Ich gucke mal kurz auf mein iPhone drauf.
Wartet mal.
Ich muss gucken.
LTE.
Moment, das iPhone 11 hat gar kein 5G, oder?
Ich kann eh nur...
Maximal LTE haben bei dem.
Welches iPhone hat denn 5G?
Ah, ab dem 12er.
Okay.
Ja, aber ich habe ja den 14er hier.
Das 14er kann es auf jeden Fall.
Also, okay.
Hier heißt...
Das heißt, hier hat...
Die Telekom hat 5G ausgebaut.
Vodafone hat Long Range 5G.
Und O2 hat ein bisschen 5G.
Aber zum größten Teil...
LTE.
Aber ich finde, man sieht schon, dass die O2-Abdeckung schlechter ist als von den anderen beiden.
Die anderen...
Also, die Telekom ist eindeutig am meisten rot.
Gefolgt von Vodafone.
Und der Rest hier bei O2 ist halt LTE.
Wobei man ganz ehrlich sagen muss, reicht ja auch.
So, aber jetzt machen wir mal was Interessanteres.
Hier gehe ich manchmal wandern.
Ja, das sieht doch schon mal ganz spannend aus.
Hier.
Ja, hier so.
Das ist die Ecke, wo ich ganz gerne mal wandern gehe.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Hessen.
Hessen-Niedersteinbach.
Ja, oder so.
Ja, mein Weg.
So, hier so in der Ecke.
Da gehe ich ganz gerne wandern.
Das heißt, hier haben wir volle Pulle LTE.
Okay.
Telekom hat...
5G und 5G DSS.
Und Vodafone hat, ähm...
Zwei...
Guck mal da.
Da ist Vodafone zum Beispiel schlechter in dem Fall als die hier.
Die haben komplett LTE überall.
Interessant.
Gibt es denn irgendwo was, wo gar nicht richtig abgedeckt ist?
So irgendwo im Osten oder so.
Also, ich finde, man sieht schon, dass hier am meisten blau ist.
Bei der Telekom ist fast alles mindestens mal lila.
Ja.
Bei Telefon ist hier schon einiges, einiges mehr blau.
Gucken wir mal hier.
So am Arsch der Welt.
Am Arsch der Welt.
Irgendwo so irgendwo.
Ja.
Groß, groß.
Muckroh.
Alles klar.
Was gibt es denn da?
Okay, sogar da hat Telekom 5G.
Aber im Ernst, so schlimm sieht es doch jetzt gar nicht aus.
Also, für mich, für mich sieht das so aus, dass eigentlich egal, mit welchem Anbieter
man in der Regel eigentlich immer mindestens 4G hat.
Bis auf kleinere Flecken.
Na gut, wenn du halt wirklich hier so am Arsch der Welt bist, dann hast du teilweise auch
gar nichts.
Telekom, wo davon, haben wir abgedeckt.
Ja.
Nur halt nicht im Zug.
Das stimmt.
Also, ich fahre hier nach Frankfurt.
So, hier ist, hier ist, hier ist quasi so die Strecke.
Irgendwo, wo ist denn hier der Hauptbahnhof?
Hier.
Hanau.
Hanau Hauptbahnhof.
Hier.
Ich fahre quasi hier lang durch Maintal.
Wo ist Maintal Ost?
Ja.
Maintal Ost.
Find man nicht.
Ne, Maintal Ost.
Hier habe ich manchmal keine gescheite Verbindung.
Wobei hier angeblich alles abgedeckt ist.
Okay.
Naja.
Also, hier Maintal Ost habe ich immer morgens, reißt immer die Verbindung ab für so ein paar
Minuten, wenn ich da mit dem Zug durchfahre.
Also, ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, man kann auch O2 verwenden.
Ja, ich sehe es so wie ihr.
Wenn man hier guckt.
Die Telekom, finde ich, kann man schon so im Großen und Ganzen sagen, ist am besten.
Gefolgt von Vodafone.
Man sieht ja auch, das ist halt viel, viel mehr blau.
Aber solange ich LTE irgendwo habe, soll mir das Recht sein.
Vor allem, wenn ich irgendwie nur die Hälfte oder so bezahlen muss.
Das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Wie sieht es eigentlich in der Nordsee aus?
Guck mal, in der Nordsee.
Ja, ich sehe es so wie ihr.
Wenn man hier guckt.
Guck mal, uns in den Nordseeочкаus.
Nun immer wieder auf종lte neighborla Grab.
Hin.
du bist nur mal ohne hand an regiment.
Vzweifel auf innen.
behälter von versuchen.
was ist breakshour was ist dasанные macht mit artillerie Перuschen und so weiter.
B abilities.
ein anrichter verbwide ausglingsmodell für demkokoliеюсьplatz.
ruining ones.
ein Karena.
mit machtelf naszegoكلan者 fotof Beni Da controls.
kleinen, kleinen
vorgelagerten Insel von
Spiegeroog bin, dann
habe ich keinen Mobile-Empfang.
Anzeige ist raus.
Interessant. So.
Was kommt denn hier oben drüber, Leute?
Dänemark? Nee.
Leute, ich kenne mich
geografisch nicht aus. Was kommt hier
oben drüber?
Ist das dann schon Niederlande?
Oder Dänemark?
Ich weiß das wirklich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Dänemark? Okay.
Niederlande ist mir links.
Nee, links ist Frankreich. Hier ist doch Frankreich, oder?
Ist die...
Hier ist Dänemark.
Nicht? Wieso? Das stimmt doch,
dass Frankreich links ist.
Frankreich ist rechts, wirklich?
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Äh. Na, was suche ich denn hier?
Google Earth
machen wir jetzt auf.
Earth-Staaten. Okay.
Wo sucht man hier was?
Frankfurt.
Ah, nein.
Da ist Frankreich.
Was labert ihr denn? Natürlich ist Frankreich links.
Wer hat erzählt, dass Frankreich
auf der rechten Seite ist, hä?
Chat. Wer hat hier schon wieder
so getan, als wisst ihr es besser?
Selbstverständlich ist Frankreich
links von Deutschland.
Wer was? Chat, wer hat hier wieder
Mist erzählt?
Der Lars hat wieder so getan.
Frankreich? Nein, ist es nicht.
Wie sie alle so tun, als
stimmt das nicht, was ich gesagt habe. Guck hier.
Da sind wir und Frankreich ist links von uns.
Oder westlich von uns.
Westlich von uns, könnte man auch sagen.
Okay, hier oben ist Dänemark.
Wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich
da drauf gekommen wieder?
Die Niederlande sind da.
Holen ist da. Okay, alles klar.
Hier. Und übrigens, Leute, wisst
ihr eigentlich, dass ich hier wohne?
In Andorra.
Irgendwo hier.
Wo auch immer genau
überhaupt Andorra jetzt
ist. Andorra.
Ne, das
nicht. Zumindest, ich
wohne auf Twitter in Andorra.
Allerdings in den Pyrenäen
das. Laut
Twitter. Ist das das
hier? Ist das in den Pyrenäen das? Ja,
genau. Hier. Auf
Twitter wohne ich hier.
Und der Grund, warum ich auf
Twitter hier wohne, ist einzig und allein,
weil ich die deutschen Trends auf Twitter nicht aushalte.
Da ist nichts.
Da ist gar nichts. Ja.
Aber das
wegen ist da auch ruhig.
Da ist auf Twitter
einmal im Jahr
trendet auf Andorra, wenn die
Tour de France hier lang fährt, gibt's
einmal im Jahr einen Trend auf Twitter
Andorra. Irgendwie Le Tour
Tour de France und ansonsten
nichts. Keine Trends auf Andorra.
Einmal im Jahr gibt's
was. Es war
es trendete letztens
nochmal irgendwas, als
die in Spanien, da gab's doch so
so
Aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal Handy-Tarife weitergucken
Ich muss irgendwas bestellen, weil es wird wirklich eng
Also ich muss das die nächste Woche, muss ich meine Rufnummer umziehen lassen
Okay, das machen wir schon mal nicht
Lass doch mal hier durchgucken, ob die Seite was taugt
Ob man da auch das alles auswählen kann
Urlaubsreise, Mietwagen, weder noch
Handy, Handy mit Vertrag, Handy-Tarif
Nur SIM-Karte, sehr gut
So, Vertragslaufzeit 1 Monat
Sagen wir ab 10G, wenn überhaupt
Und wo kann ich jetzt einstellen, kann man da noch irgendwelche Custom-Sachen einstellen
So wie ich möchte Multi-SIM und
Ne, kann man nicht, das ist ja doof
Dann bringt mir der Vergleich auch nicht
Ne, kann man nicht einstellen
E-SIM
Ne, das bringt mir nichts
Haben Sie Fragen?
Sie erreichen uns innerhalb einer Minute
Ne, ne, wir müssen Sarah jetzt nicht anrufen
Dr. Sim
Ist ein Anbieter von denen, habe ich noch nie was gehört
Dann lasst uns doch jetzt mal bei O2 gucken
Dr. Sim klingt sehr vertrauenswürdig
Ja, finde ich auch
Du zahlst 25 Euro für 20 GB bei der Telekom
Wie machst du das?
Ich bezahle bei der Telekom für 20 GB 55 Euro
Aber nur mit E-SIM bringt mir doch nichts
Ach so, Young-Tarif
Da bin ich zu alt für
Oder ich frage den Chainlaw, ob der die Sache für mich abschließt
Der ist noch young genug und kann das machen
Hm
So
Klar, mobil
Ich möchte meine Rufnummer mitnehmen, korrekt
Äh
Okay, Telekom
Yep
Denied
Hahaha
Gibt's erst gar nicht
Guck mal, guck mal, was O2 zu bieten hat
Mobilfunk
Handys mit Vertrag
Handytarife
Was haben wir denn hier?
O2-Kunde
Nein, unter 29
Nein, über 60
Nein, Selbstständige
Ja, aber das ist wahrscheinlich noch teurer, hä?
Selbstständiger Tarif kostet 22,49 6G
Und normal kostet
Okay, was bringt's mir dann, dass ich selbstständig bin, Mann?
Das ist ja noch teurer
Ja, Leute, in
In, in, ähm
23 Jahren
Kann ich mir das dann holen
Bald 60 plus
Ja
Okay, gewählte Mindestlaufzeit
No pass
Nein
Oh
Mindestlaufzeit
Keine Mindestlaufzeit
So
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied jetzt zwischen Mindestlaufzeit und ohne Mindestlaufzeit?
Hä?
Doppeltes Datenvolumen
3 plus 3
Okay, ohne Laufzeit 6
Ich weiß nicht, ob das denen nicht klar ist, aber 6 ist das gleiche wie 3 plus 3
Quickmuffs
Ansonsten sehe ich da ehrlich gesagt wenig Unterschied
Anschlussgebühr?
Ne, die Anschlussgebühr ist
Anschlussgebühr ist auch dabei
Keine Ahnung, was da der Unterschied sein soll
Warum ich überhaupt 24 Monate Laufzeit nehmen sollte
Die Augen befeuchten
Dazu kann ich nur sagen
Man hat eine Laufzeit, die man nicht befeuchten kann
Man hat einen natürlichen Augenbefeuchter
Und das nennt sich Augenlider
Die kann man ab und zu zumachen und dann wieder aufmachen
Und dann sind die Augen befeuchtet
Ich weiß, richtiges Hexenwerk, aber das hat jeder
Das kommt quasi per Default
Wie kann sowas eigentlich legal sein?
Stimmt
Moment, Moment, Moment
Die haben Tarife für unter 29 und über 60
Und nicht für Leute dazwischen
Also, die haben Tarife für unter 29 und über 60
Also, das ist eindeutig
Dann, ähm, Age-Shaming
Oder?
Ich finde, wir sollten die mal Shitstormen auf Twitter dazu
Ja, das geht ja gar nicht
Das ist, das ist Age-Shaming
Best, Best-Ager-Diskriminierung
Wie viele YouTube-Tabs ich offen habe
Also, schätzungsweise
Plus
Nochmal 20
Ich hab ganz YouTube auf
Du kannst ja einen Twitter-Trend in Andorra machen
Coole Idee
Bei Autor musst du, glaube ich, in einen Shop gehen
Nee, das kann ich hier online bestellen
Okay, also
Dann lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz gucken
Haben die nichts?
Sag mal, was ist denn das schon wieder?
6 Gigabyte?
40 Gigabyte
Wie wär's denn zum Beispiel mit 12?
Anstatt 6, 40
Okay, die haben 6, 40 Unlimited
Oder wie?
Nee, Moment, da gibt's doch 120
Und es gibt noch Unlimited
Warum ist Unlimited?
Okay, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's verwirrend
Warum ist Unlimited billiger als 120?
Je
Habt ihr das gesehen?
2 Mbit
2 Mbit?
Dafür soll ich doch Geld bezahlen
Das ist ja quasi fast das
Was du bei anderen
In der Welt
Bekommst, wenn dein Datenvolumen
Abgelaufen ist
Okay, wir haben so Unlimited
Smart, das kostet das gleiche
Wie 120G
Da ist schon 10M
Ja, das ist doch Shit, oder?
Ah, okay, die wollen im Prinzip
Dass du Unlimited unbegrenzt kaufst
Also eigentlich kannst du diese 2
Du kannst diese 2 Tarife vergessen
Du kannst, du kannst
Diese 2 Tarife vergessen, im Prinzip haben die
6, 40
120 und Unlimited
Der Rest ist irgendwie so ein
Zwischending
Ich fänd's allerdings wirklich ganz cool
Ich hab ne Backe in der Seite gefunden, Leute
Guck mal
Ne, jetzt ist es wieder
Jetzt ist es wieder okay
Eben stand da noch 20 plus 20 und hier unten
Stand
Ohne Laufzeit weiterhin
Na gut, also, okay
Das ist ja durchaus
In Ordnung eigentlich, ja
Also wenn man sich das mal anguckt
40G
40G ist halt mehr als ich brauche
20, 20 ist okay, ja
Eine Multicard kostet bei denen 10 Euro im Monat
Ganz schön teuer
Gucken wir mal
O2
Multicard
Ach, nicht Multisim
2 dazu können wir
Woher weiß man, was es kostet?
Kosten
Bei der Multicard Option fallen bei jeder zusätzlichen Simkarte Kosten
Hä?
Okay
Kosten
Was kostet Multicard?
Für die Multicard kann tarifabhängig eine Aktivierungsgebühr je nach Karte anfangen sowie
nach O2-Tarif monatliche Kosten
Das im Tarif anhört sich durch die schlichte
Mit O2-Connect können sie unsere Neubes
Hä?
Warum ist das so undurchsichtig?
Was wollt ihr mit O2-Connect?
Ist das der Nachfolger von
Wo ist Carlos Matos?
Also?
Also mit O2-Connect können sie unsere neuen Tarifen
Was ist O2-Connect?
O2-Free-Connect?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was sie von mir wollen hier
Was wollen die überhaupt von mir?
Okay, also
Wir probieren es mal aus
Zum Warenkorb
Keine Auswahl
Die wollen mir nicht allen Ernstes erzählen, dass sie standardmäßig so ein Shit hier ausgewählt haben, oder?
Weiter ohne Auswahl
Und woher weiß ich jetzt?
Du sparst insgesamt
Bei was, bei was spare ich?
Hä?
Ein Monat mal 5?
Stand in der Tarifübersicht was?
Ich würde es gerne einfach mal zusammengerechnet haben, was es
Connect-Option
Nutze dein Datenvolumen auf allen deinen Geräten ohne
Einen extra
Cent für
Zwei SIM-Karten auf Wunsch
Auch als erhältst du automatisch
Über die gratis
Mein O2-Upkanzlerbequemleinfeld
Also ich würde jetzt fast so sagen
Das ist umsonst dabei
Multi, Multi-SIM
Okay, nice, hier steht ja noch weniger Informationen dazu
Also so wie ich das verstehe ist die
Ist die zweite SIM-Karte hier dabei
Umsonst
Ja
Das klingt doch eigentlich, klingt doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll
So heißt es im Endeffekt
Bei
O2
Würde ich 29 Euro im Monat bezahlen
Für
Zwei SIM-Karten
Und 40 GB
Volumen
Die unterstützen E-SIM
Und bis zu, keine Ahnung, bis zu 10 SIM-Karten oder so
Das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht
Find das ist, das ist, das ist durchaus interessante Kondition, ja
Wenn es dann auch wirklich so ist, wie das, wie man das jetzt denkt
Du kannst da noch 25 Euro draus machen
Echt, wie denn?
Hi-Fat
Nur mit der Connect-Option
Aber die sind doch dabei
Guck, Produktdetails, Connect-Option
Die, die, die ist dabei
Zwei Zusatz-E-SIMs mit Telefonie
Plus Karten nur mit Datenvolumen
Ja, das ist doch wunderbar
Moment
Zweitvertrag für 10 Euro
Dann ist der Hauptvertrag 50% günstiger
Moment
Wenn ich zwei Verträge abschließe, heißt das, es ist unterm Strich billiger?
Was?
Wie jetzt?
Moment
Wait, what?
Okay, Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen
Also du, du, du, du, du meinst quasi, wenn ich jetzt noch den billigsten Tarif nehme, ja
Moment, Moment
Der billigste kostet ja schon 20 Euro
Da blickt doch keiner mehr
Da blickt doch keiner mehr durch
Ne, okay, das, das juckt, das juckt den auf jeden Fall nicht
Ähm, oder
Moment, vielleicht muss ich da nach was anderem gucken
Vielleicht muss ich da, Kombi, vielleicht muss ich da nach Kombi-Angeboten gucken
Zweit- und Partnerkarte, vielleicht sowas in der Richtung
Ich, das ist mega undurchsichtig alles
O2 Free S-Boost
Ah, yes
Prepaid
Was haben wir da?
50% Rabatt
Volles Datenvolumen zum Altenpreis
Und das kostet 20 Euro
Warum gibt es
Jetzt seriously, warum gibt es
Warum gibt es nicht einfach das hier
In dem anderen
Und, und, und mit 5G
Das wäre doch optimal für mich
Das sind, na okay, 12 ist ein bisschen wenig
Ach, scheiß drauf
Also, ich, ich finde das Ding hier gar nicht mal so übel, ehrlich gesagt
Gucken, was die mir jetzt sagen
Das finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht
19 Euro
Moment, das ist
Hä, ich habe doch den anderen
Ach, meine Güte
Alter, was eine Seite
Das hier meine ich, das da
Oh
Keine Auswahl, weiter
Wunderbar
Okay, jetzt 30, 30 Euro im Monat
Es gibt
Multiple Sims
E-Sims
Und alles mögliche
Das ist doch gut, das kann man doch, kann man doch nehmen
Theoretisch könnte ich das vielleicht wirklich für meine Mutter noch was abschließen
Wie sieht es mit reinen Datentarifen aus?
Wäre das günstiger?
Ja, reine Datentarife will ich nicht
Ich muss ja da ab und zu auch mal drüber telefonieren
Also, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde
Hey, meine Mutter nimmt das auch
Wobei, nö, das ist immer noch teurer als ihr in Aldi Talk
Also, lohnt sich nicht
Okay, dann, dann
Läuft es wahrscheinlich auf
30 Euro raus
50% auf die
Okay, zeig mal her
Priority, bis zu 50% Rabatt für Familie und Freunde auf einen O2-Muhr- oder Datenvertrag
Warum gibt es da eine eigene Seite und sie zeigen das nicht bei der anderen Sache an?
Mit O2-Freude bereiten
Bitte loggen Sie, ich habe keinen Account
Oh Mann
Online im Shop
Online im Shop oder über die Hotline den neuen Code online unter...
Leute, hat jemand einen O2-Freundescode für mich?
So, ähm...
Follow for follow
Äh...
Für wen gilt das Angebot?
Warte mal, ey
Also, wenn du einen hast, nicht im Twitch-Chat posten, ne?
Lieber im, schick's mir lieber im Discord oder so
Aber nee, nee
Also, ich muss sagen
Ich finde das hier gar nicht mal so schlecht
Dieses, diese, diese, äh...
Den Tarif, den es hier gerade gibt
Wir gucken jetzt nochmal
Wir gucken jetzt nochmal, was Vodafone zu bieten hat
Stimmt, Chainlore
Ja, aber ich weiß immer noch nicht, ob ich dazu ein Video machen will
Mir fällt nichts Gescheites ein
So, Telekom haben wir schon geguckt
Das heißt, jetzt wird's Zeit für die hier
Was haben die denn zu bieten?
Mobilfunk?
Finde dein Mobilfunk-Angebot
Chat, ich bin ja bei Vodafone, ja?
Ich hab ja mein normales Zeug auch bei Vodafone
Dann könnte das vielleicht sogar billiger sein
Die Sache ist nur die
Wie verhält sich das dann, wenn ich mein normales Internet-Zeug bei Vodafone kündige
Und mein Handy dann weiterbehalten will?
Dann...
Dann wird das teurer
Vertrag ohne Smartphone
Angebot für alle Selbständigen
Ist das billig?
Ich habe Internet und Festnetz
Oh, ein bisschen billiger, okay
Also, die haben Giga-Chat Mobile
Da sind wir schon bei 34 Euro
Für unbegrenzt
Wie jetzt?
Das ist sass
Das ist sass, das glaube ich euch nicht
10% Rabatt für Selbständige
Du solltest bei der Rufnummer und Portierung darauf achten
Ob du die Rufnummer und Portierung nimmst oder nicht
Ob du die Rufnummer immer innerhalb des gleichen Netzanbieters überhaupt mitnehmen kannst
Du meinst, wenn ich von der Telekom zur Telekom gehe
Man kann doch immer seine Telefonnummer mitnehmen
Ach nee, du meinst, wenn ich von Telekom zur Telekom gehe, dass sie sagt
Hä, jetzt wie? Du wechselst doch gar nicht
Also meine Arbeit hat den Vertrag aktuell bei der Telekom
Das ist sass, dass das unbegrenzt ist
Richtig, richtig suß
Vertrag ohne Smartphone
Schau mal, Speed
Wo sieht man das?
5G
Oh
Tarifdetails
Unbegrenzt
Datenvolumen
Widerspricht sich das jetzt nicht irgendwie?
Leute, widerspricht sich 30G durchgestrichen unbegrenzt nicht etwa hier mit 30G?
Ich sag doch, das ist extrem sass wieder
Was da läuft?
Unbegrenzt heißt bei denen schlicht und ergreifend
Die schalten mich nicht ab, aber kein Anbieter schaltet mich mehr ab
Sondern du wirst halt gedrosselt
Ja geil
Gigakombi
Was woll...
Boah, die gehen mir schon wieder so auf den Sack, man
Kann es nicht einfach offensichtlich sein, was man bekommt dafür und gut ist?
Ich will auch gar nichts kombinieren, ich will einfach einen Handyvertrag haben
Gigamobile M L L Red M Red L Giga XL Red XS Young M Plus L Plus M Minus L Plus XSL 2019
Was zum Teufel ist bei euch los?
Was ist bei euch verkehrt?
Way to tank, Alter
Oh
War das gerade Deutschrap?
Ne, da hätte ich noch erzählen müssen, dass ich die Bitches ficke oder sowas
Ohne geht das bei Deutschrap nicht
Was ich aber schon mal sehr interessant finde, Leute, ist
Ach ja
Wisst ihr, was ich sehr interessant finde?
Dass das Angebot für Selbstständige
Günstiger ist
Guck mal
Ach hier ist wirklich unbegrenzt, okay?
Also dass das für Selbstständige
Günstiger ist
Als für Nicht-Selbstständige
Oder ist das eine inklusive Steuern und das andere nicht inklusive Steuern?
Ah Moment
Mindestvertragslaufzeit
Bei beidem
Wie kann ich den Mindestvertragslauf
Ich will keine 24 Monate Mindestvertragslaufzeit, geht mir mit dem Scheiß weg, Mann
Okay, probieren wir das mal
Alle Preise inklusive Mehrwertsteuer
Ja, nö
Ich will aber
Meine Firma ist im Handelsregister eingetragen
Äh
Ich bin IHK-Mitglied, bin ich dann im Handelsregister eingeladen?
Oder ist das was, was ich hätte extra machen müssen?
Also ich hab kein extra Handelsregister-Eintrag irgendwie meines Wissens nach machen lassen
Ne, okay
Ja, das hab ich, das hab ich
Ja, nachweisen kann ich das
Ich hab ja noch den
Wie hieß das Amt?
Keine Ahnung
Die Bestätigung von dem Amt, wo ich damals gewesen bin
Du hast einen Code
Lass uns das mal nachher im Discord ausprobieren, falls du im Discord bist
Jetzt nicht, jetzt nicht
Oder du kannst mir das Theorie
Warte, doch
Daku, ich weiß wie wir das machen
Ich schreib dich mal kurz an
Über Twitch, die Twitch, ähm
Glub
Über die Twitch-Chat-Funktion
Das ist quasi, ähm
Private Message über Twitch
Danke, ich probier das nachher mal aus
Mit, mit Code wär das natürlich konkurrenzlos billig
Extremely, extremely pogu
Dann kauf ich mir einfach was mit, mit geschnortem Gutscheincode aus dem Chat
Das ist doch was
Da hab ich wenigstens was von
Nice
Exquisite
Warte lieber auf Black Friday
Ich kann nicht warten
Ich hab noch zwei Wochen Zeit, mir einen neuen Vertrag zu suchen
Was natürlich richtig billig ist, Leute
Wenn man Vodafone-Kunde ist und selbstständig
Guckt mal
Äh
Moment
Ach, unbegrenzt gibt es gar nicht für
Wenn du Vodafone-Kunde bist, darfst du nicht unbegrenzt machen
Wie viele, wie viel Datenvolumen brauchst du?
Stimmt, ich brauch sogar nur weniger
Ist auch noch verkehrt
Ähm
Ja, das reicht
Also, ich hab halt gesagt, so um die 20
Nee, es ist inklusive Mehrwertsteuer
Steht da
Es ist inklusive Mehrwertsteuer
Das muss ich mir tatsächlich nochmal angucken
So, so blöd, so blöd finde ich die Idee gar nicht
Das bei Vodafone zu holen
Okay, also
Weil ich mein selbstständig
Den Nachweis kann ich denen schicken
Also hab ich jetzt zur Auswahl
Also ich hätte einmal
Also ob, ganz ehrlich, für mich ist jetzt der Unterschied
Ähm
21 Gig
Oder?
Was wollen die eigentlich?
Warum steht hier 15?
Wenn es doch
Wenn es doch 21 ist
Kann mir mal jemand erklären
Warum muss das so unglaublich shady und undurchsichtig sein alles immer?
Warum kann da nicht einfach stehen, ohne Sternchen, ohne irgendeinen Scheiß
Einfach das, das, das, das
Kost am Ende das
Fertig
Für mich haben die das erhört
Oh, die sind aber
Die sind aber so nett, dass sie es für mich erhöhen
Die sind so nett, dass sie es für mich erhöhen, sodass sie es nicht reinschreiben
Ach, guck mal
Man kann auch
Wait a minute
Was ist das denn jetzt schon?
Warum kostet es?
Ne, das ist doch genau das gleiche
Internet?
Was?
Internet und Telefonie?
Ja gut
Mobilfunk, Internet und Telefonie
Ja, okay, aber
Ich, ich find's, ich find's extrem, extrem unnötig
Also
An sich
Noch bei einem anderen Mobil-Anfieter jetzt
Ja, auf geht's, auch noch
Sparstellst, dann bekommst du für die Laufzeit als einfach mal
Ne
Ach Quatsch, ne, okay, das funktioniert nicht
Okay
Also, das find ich, das find ich nicht schlecht
Ja, so sieht's aus
Die Telekom hat die beste Abdeckung
Ganz ehrlich
Ich finde noch das, wie's die Telekom beschrieben hat
Noch am
Da blickt man noch am besten durch
Es ist zwar teuer
Es ist eigentlich viel, viel zu teuer, muss ich ehrlich sagen
Ich mein, nehmen wir mal das hier
45 Euro im Monat
Ach, Zusatz-SIM bei Vodafone, genau
Gut, dass ihr das sagt, Leute
Vodafone eSIM, das wird's doch geben, oder?
eSIM bestellen
Ähm
Multisim
Wo können die denn einfach was hinschreiben?
Die Vodafone
Wunderbar
Die Multisim kostet hier extra anscheinend, würd ich jetzt mal
My Deals Übersichten gecheckt, ne
Vodafone
Heißt das Multicard oder Multisim?
Ja
Multisim kosten
Multisim war im Warenkorb?
Wirklich?
eSIM war im Warenkorb
Brei
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal so teuer?
Ja
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht das, was ich angeklickt hab
Boah, Alter
Angebot für Selbstständige
21 Steine, ich will nicht sparen, aber das ist richtig so, okay
In den Warenkorb
Nutzt du deinen Internetanschluss in NRW?
Ja
Über welche bekommst du dein Internet?
Äh, Kabel
No, God!
No, God, please, no!
No!
Das ist doch absoluter Wahnsinn, Mann!
Wie kompliziert kann mans eigentlich machen?
Jetzt sind wir schon mal 35 Euro, da lohnt sich's wieder nicht
Leute ohne Scheiß, ich glaub ich nehm echt O2, easy
Ruf dort an, nö
Kein Bock
Also ohne Scheiß, wenn das mit dem QR Code funktionieren sollte
Mein- was?
DeinHandy.de. Klingt auch ein bisschen shady, oder? Und tschüss. Machen wir gar nicht auf. Ach, jetzt ist es auf einmal DeinHandy.de. Okay, das gibt es wirklich. Das ist aber einer von diesen weiteren 0815 Anbieter-Klonen, wo es total, total viele gibt.
Ähm, ich glaube, ach so, das ist, Moment, das ist gar kein Anbieter. Das ist ein Vergleichsportal oder sowas in der Richtung, oder? Ein Reseller. Aber man kann ja auch nicht Multisim und so auswählen.
Okay, Leute, scheiß drauf. Ich glaube, ohne Mist, ich tendiere tatsächlich aktuell schlicht und ergreifend hier zu.
Da blickt man auch halbwegs durch.
Nicht im Stream öffnen. Nein, ich öffne das doch nicht im Stream.
Ich gucke mir das nachher an.
Ja, ja, ich weiß. Ne, ne, ich gucke das nachher an. Ich mache das jetzt hier nicht auf.
So. Also, wenn das klappt, naja, bis zu 50% angeblich. Wobei ich das ja nicht erst glaube, wenn ich es sehe, ja.
Läuft dein Kabel-Internet-Anschluss stabil? Habe gehört, da soll es Probleme mit Geschwindigkeiten geben.
Bei Vodafone gezählt.
Da gibt es immer wieder Probleme. Ich würde eigentlich fast dazu übergehen und sagen, es gibt bei jedem Internetanbieter immer wieder Probleme.
Allerdings bei Vodafone doch relativ häufig. Ich muss aber sagen, sie haben es die letzten paar Monate, fast schon das letzte Jahr über, relativ gut hinbekommen.
Also, ich glaube, ich hatte das letzte Jahr über nur zwei, drei Tage mal Probleme, wo ich auch nicht gescheit streamen konnte.
Das ist zwar immer noch viel zu viel.
Und ich glaube mittlerweile auch, dass Vodafone...
Ich glaube, dass Vodafone mich auf irgendeine Influencer-Streamer-Liste gesetzt hat, weil ich letztens per PN von Vodafone, also letztens vor einem Jahr oder so, als ich das letzte Mal mit dem Vodafone-Support geschrieben habe, habe ich auf einmal keine Nachricht vom Support bekommen, sondern von irgendeinem komischen...
Ich sehe es jetzt gar nicht. Wo habe ich es denn?
Also, das letzte Mal, das letzte Mal, wo ich mich beschwert habe bei Vodafone...
Dass irgendwas nicht ging, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Das war schon...
Ach, ich sehe schon, das ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen länger her.
Zumindest hat dann irgendwie so ein random Typ geschrieben, der nicht vom Support war, dass ich mich bei ihm melden soll wegen Rückerstattung und sonst was.
Also, ich habe anscheinend zu sehr rumgeflamed, immer öffentlich über Vodafone.
Also, vielleicht stehe ich bei denen auf irgendeiner Streamer-Influencer-Liste drauf oder so.
Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es immer wieder Probleme.
Und ansonsten muss ich sagen, funktioniert es ganz gut.
Es ist besser, als was die Telekom bei mir zu bieten hat, weil bei mir gibt es aktuell von der Telekom nur DSL bzw. VDSL.
Und VDSL hat man zwar im Hinterkopf immer noch so als super krasses, schnelles Zeug, aber im Jahr 2000, 2023 ist VDSL halt auch nicht mehr super krasses, schnelles Zeug.
Also, insofern...
Kupfer, Keck, Alu, ja.
Es wird mal echt langsam Zeit für Glasfaser.
Ich bin der Erste in der Straße, der mir das in den Keller legen lässt, wenn die am Start sind.
Ja, also Leute, ich vermute, alte Rufnummer mitnehmen.
Ah, da steht auch noch was dazu.
Ich vermute mal, dass es tatsächlich auf O2 rauslaufen wird.
Ich finde die Kombination ganz gut, wenn das mit dem Gutschein-Code geht, noch viel besser.
Ja, alte Rufnummer einfach mitnehmen.
Die Beauftragung der Portierung geht.
Einfach schnell.
Probieren Sie es auf der folgenden Seite.
Alternativ können Sie dies auch Aktivierung Ihres Vertrags in Ihrem Online-Kundenkonto beauftragen.
Okay.
Ja, das werde ich dann machen.
Also, ich glaube, ich glaube...
Weitere Hinweise und Fußnoten.
Ah, yes.
Zum Tarif...
Hier steht es noch.
Zum Tarif können bis zu zwei weitere Multicards plus sieben Datacards zugebucht werden, die jeweils auf das im Tarifenthalter Highspeed-Datenvolumen...
...zugreifen.
Bei den Zuge realisiert...
Ja, okay.
Was wollen die sonst noch?
O2-3M-Booster-Flex.
Keine Mindestvertragslaufzeit.
Ja, das ist gut.
40 GB Datenvolumen.
Nach Verbrauch des enthaltenen Datenvolumens.
Ja, das mit 40 GB komme ich locker hin.
Das klingt doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das werde ich...
werde ich...
nehmen.
30 Euro, vielleicht mit dem Gutscheincode noch anderweitig.
Ja.
Ich glaube, da gucke ich nicht weiter.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz gut so.
Das werde ich bestellen.
Offstream.
Ich trage jetzt hier nicht meine Daten ein und den Gutscheincode.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass das dann ankommt und ich die Rufnummer im Portierraum beauftragen kann.
Exzellent.
Wunderbar.
Hätten wir das auch schon.
Was machen wir denn jetzt, Leute?
Erst eineinhalb Stunden oder eine...
fast eine Stunde 45 on.
Was machen wir denn jetzt noch?
So eine halbe Stunde irgendwas machen können wir doch.
Gibt es irgendwas Spannendes noch, worüber wir unbedingt reden müssen?
JavaScript noch?
Nee, nee, nee.
Heute kein JavaScript.
Ich kann euch übrigens noch was erzählen.
Ich kann euch...
Und zwar, ich kann euch noch was von der Arbeit erzählen.
Und zwar...
Also ich bin ja...
Ich bin ja Ende des Monats weg.
Und...
Ein Kollege von mir ist auch Ende des Monats weg.
So, und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Das müsst ihr euch mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Der ist ja auch schon Monate, wenn nicht Jahre lang dort am Nerven mit bessere Homeoffice-Regelungen, mehr Geld und sowas.
Und sie sagen ja seit Jahren immer so, oh, es ist ganz schlecht.
So, oh, jetzt war erst Corona.
Ah, jetzt ist...
Jetzt ist hier Inflation so hoch.
Und oh, das Geschäftsjahr.
Und oh, ganz schlimm.
Und sie reden sich immer raus.
So, und jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Passt mal auf.
Also, wir hauen beide Ende des Monats ab.
So.
Und jetzt haben sie ihn gefragt, ob er denn nicht bei irgendeinem Plan mitmachen will.
So, wie könnte man XYZ verbessern?
Da hat er gesagt, ja, normalerweise hätte ich da gerne mitgemacht.
Also da geht es um irgendwie so Konzept erstellen, weil er sich mit dem Thema gut auskennt.
Und ob er da was zu sagen kann.
Sagen wir mal, ja, normalerweise würde ich mitmachen.
Aber ich bin am 30.03. nicht mehr in der Firma tätig.
So, und jetzt habe ich gehört, haben die allen Ärzte überlegt, ob sie ihn nicht wieder einkaufen sollen für 7, 8 Stunden die Woche.
Allerdings dann, hat er gemeint, dann nur für externes Gehalt.
Also 80 Euro die Stunde.
Wenn die das machen würden, wäre es unglaublich bescheuert.
Man, erst sind sie so knauserig, erst sind sie so knauserig, ja, und sagen, oh, wie, was, wie, mehr Homeoffice?
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Oh, was, wie, mehr Geld?
Oh, nee, gibt's nicht.
Okay, dann kündige ich.
Ja, mach's gut, tschüss.
Äh, ach so.
Hm.
Wir können nicht auch für 80 Euro die Stunde nochmal einkaufen für 8 Stunden die Woche.
The fuck, man, seid ihr bescheuert, Alter.
80 Euro die Stunde in Frankfurt, das ist aber arg wenig.
Was ist denn gut in Frankfurt?
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich, was man da so sagen sollte.
Da muss ja auch dementsprechend versteuert werden und alles.
Hat hier jemand Bash-Skripte zu Python überführt?
Wie schwer könnte es werden?
Es geht darum, CITools-Bildtest-Upload nach Nexus.
Oh, ein Java-Entwickler.
Oder ich persönlich bevorzuge ja Java.
Okay, leider können wenige im Team Shell-Skripting.
Das dürfte nicht sonderlich schwierig sein.
Also, wahrscheinlich ist es, also je nachdem, was ihr macht,
könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es in Python nicht so schwierig ist.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich glaube, dass es in Python sogar ein bisschen einfacher ist, das Ganze zu machen,
weil wenn ihr irgendwelche anderen Tools ansprecht,
gibt es für die wahrscheinlich schon fix und fertige Python-Packages.
Dann müsst ihr gar nicht irgendwelche Bash-Befehle aufrufen
und die rumpipen und kreppen dazwischen,
sondern könntet die jeweiligen Tools direkt über ihre Python-Packages.
Wie nennt sich das bei Python eigentlich?
Bei Ruby sind es Gems, bei Rust sind es Crates.
Wie heißt es denn?
Bei Python heißt es, glaube ich, einfach nur Packages.
Packages, oder?
Packages.
Modules?
Nee, ich glaube Packages, oder?
Wie heißt das?
Pip?
Packages.
Wie heißt das offiziell?
Packages heißt das.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es schwierig ist, umzustellen, je nachdem, was ihr da macht.
Könnte es sogar einfacher sein in Python.
Nee, nee, Artifacts heißt nicht.
Python Packages.
Also, mal angenommen, ihr macht in euren Skripts,
also gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, was weiß ich,
ihr wollt irgendwie, was weiß ich,
ihr habt irgendeinen, irgendeinen,
irgendein Push-Skript, was dann irgendeinen Jenkins-Job anwirft
und irgendwelche Sachen pusht, irgendwo sonstwohin.
Da könnte es ja durchaus sein, dass es einfacher ist, das in Python zu machen,
weil ihr dann das offizielle Jenkins-Python-Package verwenden könnt,
das offizielle Nexus-Python, also Nexus-API-Python-Package verwenden könnt,
dass es sogar einfacher ist, das in Python zu machen, als in Bash.
Dass es einfacher ist und vielleicht sogar besser funktioniert.
Nee, da würde ich mir wenig Gedanken drüber machen.
Ich persönlich mag Bash-Skripte schon,
wenn es halt Sachen verwendet, die schon da sind,
ja, wo man relativ einfach mit den vorhandenen Tools was bauen kann.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ich habe im,
für solche Sachen finde ich das,
oh, was will er denn, Units?
Ähm, das ist kein Bug.
Ich glaube, er versteht, ich glaube, er versteht die,
den Output falsch.
Das ist der Output, wie sein Home Assistant eingestellt ist.
Sein Home Assistant ist auf Celsius und Kilometer.
Die Werte selbst kommen in Miles konvertiert, wenn er diese Option macht.
Egal.
Ähm, was ich jetzt eigentlich sagen wollte, ich habe hier so ein Mini, Mini, Minist-Build-Skript
für Sachen, die ich immer vergesse, ja.
Ich kopiere die Readme in die richtige Datei.
Ähm, ich, und ich hole mir den Version-Tag raus.
So, fertig.
Also, für sowas finde ich Bash sinnvoll.
Das ist jetzt wirklich eine ganz, ganz kleine Variante.
Für so Sachen, die man jedes Mal wieder neu tippen müsste.
Dafür finde ich so Bash natürlich besser, besser geeignet.
Das ist als jede andere Sprache.
Das machst du in nie keiner Sprache so einfach wie ein Bash, sowas hier.
Aber wenn man größere Sachen machen will, ist es wahrscheinlich sogar einfacher,
das in Python zu machen.
Und wenn es dafür offizielle Packages gibt, noch, noch, noch besser.
Ihr labert jetzt.
Also 100, ohne, unter 100 Euro auf keinen Fall.
Sagst du mit Vermittler dazwischen oder nicht?
Sehne und Def in Frankfurt, als kann, dann kann es schon dreistellig gehen.
Ja, ich habe jetzt einfach noch nur irgendwas gesagt.
Vielleicht sollten wir sogar noch mehr sagen.
Ich frag die einfach mal, ob ich nicht auch noch ein paar Stunden die Woche zusätzlich was machen soll.
Ey, ich hab montags viel Zeit.
Einfach jeden Monat nochmal, jeden Montag vier Stunden, 400 Euro, BÄM.
Wobei, ohne Scheiß, Leute, das würde ich nicht machen.
Wisst ihr, warum ich das nicht machen würde?
Der Grund, warum ich Teilzeit arbeite, ist ja, weil mir die Kohle reicht und ich mehr Zeit haben will.
Hier, für Streaming, YouTube und andere Sachen, die mich interessieren.
Und...
Und ich bin mittlerweile auf einem Gehaltsniveau angelangt.
Ich denke, da kann man ohne Probleme sagen, man kommt damit gut aus.
Und mehr ist zwar immer nice, aber muss auch nicht notwendigerweise sein.
Also dann habe ich lieber mehr Freizeit.
Rache Klos schreibt, aber bei mir lief es genauso, Max.
Einsatzbereitschaft sollte ich zeigen bei schon 60...
Moment, so viel darf man doch gar nicht, oder?
Ja.
Ist nicht bei 48.
Oder so die Woche Schluss.
Aber mehr Geld sollte es nicht geben.
Gekündigt nicht mal zwei Mal, nachdem ich nicht mehr da war, gab es die Antwort, wir kaufen nicht ein.
Ja, beste.
Beste ist doch gut für dich.
Ja, die normalen IT-Dienstleister, wenn du zu irgendeiner Programmierer-Entwicklerbude gehst, was die dann abrechnet.
Aber es geht ja hier um einen einzelnen Typ.
Keine Ahnung, ich muss mich da mal schlau machen.
Es geht nicht um mich.
Es geht überhaupt nicht um mich.
Das falsche Mindset.
Fuck, Leute.
Ich gebe es zu.
Ich habe nicht das High-Performer-Mindset.
Wird nicht genug gehaschelt.
Und so kommen wir auch nicht auf den Mount Everest.
Aber kann ich aber mit leben.
Dafür mache ich was Sinnvolles in meiner Zeit.
Außer andere Leute zu scammen und denen zu erzählen, wie sie erfolgreich werden.
Und erfolgreich werden heißt, kein sinnvolles Geschäftsmodell haben, sondern den ursprünglichen Erfinder reich machen.
Und nicht die Leute selbst.
Dafür mache ich was sinnvolles mit meiner Zeit.
Und erzähle nicht irgendwie, scamme nicht irgendwelche Leute.
Es geht auch ohne das High-Performer-Mindset.
Mal gucken.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob die das ihm anbieten.
So nach dem Motto, wir kaufen dich ein.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall witzig.
Oh, mein Auge, Mann.
Das ist bestimmt O2-Reseller hier.
Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus.
Ne, ne.
So, das sollte ich mir mal angucken.
Hat letztens jemand im Chat geschrieben.
Was ist das?
30 Dollar USB-Switch into full-featured KVM.
Also so ein Umschaltding für Tastaturen.
Was heißt denn das überhaupt?
Keyboard, Video.
Ne, was heißt denn KVM überhaupt?
Keyboard?
Ich weiß gar nicht, für was KVM steht.
Switch.
Für was steht KVM überhaupt?
Video, Maus.
Keyboard, Video, Maus.
Aha, da hätte ich auch selbst drauf kommen können.
This turns a simple USB-Switch into a full-fledged KVM-Solution.
Press one button on your USB-Switch and all your...
Äh.
Und wie soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Oh.
Auge.
Erblindet.
Okay, USB.
Ja, ein USB-Switch.
Okay, und jetzt?
Ach so.
Moment.
Der hat die Monitore schon an den Geräten angepasst.
Angeschlossen.
Und er schaltet dann nur den Monitor-Input um, oder?
Das ist doch...
Das hat dann aber mit KVM über Netzwerk nichts wirklich zu tun.
Oder sehe ich das jetzt falsch?
Das ist doch G-Bait.
Ja.
Ja, das...
Okay, das...
Ne, das bringt ja dann nicht wirklich was.
Das ist cool, wenn man zwei Monit...
Wenn man hier zwei Rechner hat, die man unabhängig voneinander benutzen will und dann die Tastatur darüber umschalten will und sowas.
Ja, okay.
Aber...
Richtigen KVM-Ersatz ist es nicht.
Weil eine richtig gute KVM...
Und der richtige Vorteil von einem KVM ist ja auch, wenn die netzwerkfähig sind,
dass du zum Beispiel an einen Server gehen kannst, der gar nichts mehr macht,
und dann dort übers Netzwerk drauf zugreifen kannst.
Ansonsten ist das ja eher so Convenience auf dem Schreibtisch hier.
Moin Patrick, danke für den Sub.
44 Monate.
Massive Subscription.
Nice.
P.K.V.M.
Wisst ihr was, Leute?
Oder man geht zu Ebay und kauft sich ein...
Ich hab vergessen, wie diese Dinger heißen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Äh, IP KVM Connect.
Irgendwas...
Tronic oder so hieß der Kram?
Ne.
Ähm...
Fuck.
Wie hieß das Ding, was ich mir gekauft hab?
Hier.
Landronix.
Spider.
Die hat 70 Euro oder so gekostet damals bei Ebay.
Hab ich sofort zugeschleppt.
Die gab's mal im Dutzend billiger.
What?
Was?
Warum ist das so...
Alter!
Was ist denn mit euch los?
270 Euro Versand.
Kannst du damit auch Setup machen?
Ja, klar.
Kannst du.
Du schließt das an?
Ja.
Per VGA.
Wenn man auch VGA hat.
Lol.
Du schließt das an per VGA und USB und dann kommst du, kommst du so, kannst du auch ins
BIOS und alles.
Krass.
Alter.
Ja, man...
Na, der IP KVM ist, äh, Raspberry Pi aktuell zu kriegen, ist auch kein Ding.
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, wenn es 70 Euro kostet, ist man da gut dabei, weil man hat ne fertig
funktionierende Lösung.
Alter, warum ist das denn so unglaublich teuer, man, mittlerweile?
Davon habe ich noch keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Ich hab mich in der ...
..
Fuck.
Und warum kostet ein Rechner von 1995 so viel?
Warum?
Was ist mit denen los?
Warum ist das so teuer das Teil?
Ne, das ist gar kein Rechner, oder?
Das ist ein CD Brenner.
Ne oder…
Was ist das überhaupt?
Ein Print Server.
Äh...
Warum nicht einfach, ne netzt...
Sprinting.
Also, dass die Dinger so teuer sind
mittlerweile, ist
mega heftig.
Wie gesagt, ich hab
ich hab dafür 70 Euro
oder sowas in dem Dreh bezahlt.
Na gut, bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen
kann ich ja nicht mehr kaufen, weil die mich ja gebannt haben.
Du hattest Glück.
Das kann sein.
Allerdings, zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo ich das gekauft hab, gab es ganz
viele auf Ebay dazu,
so in diesem Dreh.
Das ist jetzt nix, also
hätte ich jetzt gedacht, oh krass, super Schnäppchen
gemacht, hätte ich es wahrscheinlich auch anders erzählt.
Was ich
gemacht habe bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen,
ich hatte nie einen Account
bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen.
Und ich wollte dann einen Account bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen
anlegen und
da stand dann sinngemäß
irgendwie sowas wie,
also als ich dann die E-Mail Adresse eingegeben
hab, stand dann, also nee genau, ich wollte
einen Account anlegen und da hat es irgendwie
gesagt, es gebe für die
E-Mail Adresse schon was und da wollte ich
die E-Mail Adresse eingeben und da haben sie gesagt,
ich wurde gebannt. Ich hatte nie
einen Account, ich habe nie Ebay Kleinanzeigen benutzt.
Und da habe ich
an den Support geschrieben, von Ebay
Kleinanzeigen
und da haben die
gar nichts Sinnvolles geantwortet, sondern
nur geschrieben, bitte bleiben
sie unserem Marktplatz fern.
Ich habe es nie benutzt, für nichts.
Also,
das höchste der Gefühle ist,
dass ich irgendwann mal,
gesagt habe,
ich will einen Account anlegen
und diesen Account Setup Prozess
nie completed habe.
Das kann durchaus sein,
dass ich mich da mal quasi
so eine Invite E-Mail hab
schicken lassen und dann
das nie abgeschlossen habe.
Das kann sein,
dass es da schon was gab, aber ich habe es nie benutzt.
Ja, das kann man
machen, aber das sehe ich nicht ein.
Also, wer mir so eine dreiste
ähm
Arschantwort schickt,
ohne da irgendwie drauf einzugehen,
dem seine Plattform verwende ich auch nicht.
Ich kann jetzt, Moment Leute, ich gucke mal kurz
bei Ebay. Ich hoffe, ich kann mich bei Ebay noch einloggen.
Hallo Max, ab sofort
verkaufst du kostenlos. Okay, mein Ebay.
Fuck, jetzt muss ich mich doch
mit dem Passwort einloggen.
Ähm, okay.
Oder habe ich damals sogar bei Amazon
gekauft?
Kaufübersicht.
Hier, Kaufübersicht.
Äh,
kaufe. Landronix.
Steht nicht drin.
Weil?
Weil es älter als 6 Monate
ist, oder? Kann das
sein, dass das rausfliegt aus Ebay,
wenn es älter als 6 Monate ist?
Ich guck mal, ich guck mal in meinen,
ich guck mal in meinen E-Mails.
Falls Ebay auf diese E-Mail-Adresse
geht. Oh, Hetzner
hat mir eine Rechnung geschickt. Was ist das?
Ha! Null.
Guck mal.
Hetzner Rechnung.
Hetzner Rechnung vom letzten Monat.
Huge.
4 Cent.
Jetzt wird's aber eng.
Äh, Landronix.
Kaufbestätigung.
Kaufbestätigung. Ebay. 2019
habe ich das gekauft. Kaufbestätigung.
Vielen Dank für den Kauf.
79,99.
Sag ich doch.
Habe ich bezahlt dafür.
Ich habe
so ein Gerät gekauft.
Kann sogar noch die,
steht sogar noch die, die, die, ähm,
die Artikelnummer drin, ne?
Wer bezahlt eigentlich Archiv.wublos.tv?
Das bezahlt das Series Max
und ich habe mich aber auch dran beteiligt.
Wir bezahlen das aktuell zusammen.
Wobei ich glaube, das aktuelle Jahr,
das habe ich nicht,
das aktuelle Jahr sogar
bezahlt
im Voraus.
War da nicht irgendwie, oder war das für was anderes?
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Du hast deinen ersten,
Github-Sponsor bekommen. Nice.
Für dein, für dein Wake-on-LAN-Projekt
oder für was?
Also wie gesagt, Leute, dieses Ding habe ich bestellt.
79 Euro.
1 Euro von dem Creator von Noted.lol
Dazu ist ja quasi,
da schwimmst du jetzt ja im Geld.
Ich hatte mal irgendwie so eine Geld-Animation,
aber hier doch.
Also, interessant, dass es die Dinge jetzt nur für 500 plus gibt,
wenn ich sie für 79 Euro gekauft habe bei Ebay.
Alles klar. Nice.
GG Eats.
Und wisst ihr, was mich auch extrem beeindruckt hat bei den Dingern,
aber wirklich massive?
Ich kann es euch nochmal zeigen.
Archive.
KVM?
Ah, geiles Game.
Müsste ich auch mal wieder spielen.
Mega Game.
Messiah of Might and Magic.
Das war ein richtig geiles Game.
So.
Gibt es mal ein wenig Hintergrundwissen
zur Technologie von Archive.wublos.tv
Du kannst es auf Github angucken.
Oder das Video des Max erzählt da bestimmt auch was zu,
wenn du ihn fragst.
Ich weiß, es ist, glaube ich, ein Vue.js Frontend
und ein Go-Backend,
wenn ich jetzt nicht totalen Mist erzähle.
Ne, ein Svelte Frontend.
Es ist ein Svelte Frontend und ein Go-Backend.
Und dieses ganze Postgres ist für die Suche, glaube ich.
Postgres ist für die Suche.
Und dieses Transcribe-Zeug ist über Cloud,
Cloud, Cloud.
Und GPU-Kisten mit AI extrahiert worden.
Ist es Vue.js oder ist es Svelte, das Frontend?
Ja, Svelte ist es, sage ich.
Ja, das ist doch gar nicht so verkehrt, was ich gesagt habe.
Pogu.
Ist das Vertragsthema schon abgefrühstückt?
Ja, es wird wahrscheinlich auf diesen Vertrag hier rauslau...
Wahrscheinlich läuft es darauf raus, vertragstechnisch.
Ne, keine Angular-Enjoyers.
Und ernsthaft,
ich glaube, es wird auf diesen Vertrag hier rauslau...
Ich glaube, es wird auf diesen Vertrag hier rauslau...
Ich glaube, ich werde auch nie Angular-Enjoyer werden.
Ne, habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Aber die haben wahrscheinlich
keine Multi-SIM und keine
E-SIM?
Multi-SIM?
Ne, haben sie nicht.
Ich glaube, es läuft hierauf raus.
Pogu.
Ja, ich brauche es für mehrere Geräte.
Genau.
Nachdem ich keine Vertragslaufzeit habe,
also nur einen Monat, kann ich einfach auch woanders hin,
wenn es gar so beschissen ist mit dem Empfang.
Aber ich denke hier Frankfurt
und Umgebung wird das schon ganz gut funktionieren.
Was ist das?
Clean Code Horrible Performance.
Ist das C++?
Ah!
No!
Oh Gott!
Oh Gott, please no!
No!
Ah, wenn ich das schon sehe.
I!
C++.
Warum habe ich das Video offen?
Ich habe das Video offen.
What the?
Ich glaube, jetzt weiß ich, warum ich das offen habe,
weil es große Wellen auf Hacker-News geschlagen hat, oder?
Wollen wir das noch angucken?
Ich glaube, das ist kein gutes Material
für Sonntag-Aufwachen-Stream.
Kommentare aus...
Das ist wohl Standard bei dem.
Ich habe mir andere Videos angeguckt.
Ich dachte auch zuerst, dass die Hacker-News
Rust-Task-Force
zu sehr zugeschlagen hat.
Warum habe ich hier eigentlich
nicht...
Moment, Moment.
Ich brauche hier nicht...
Ich brauche doch hier noch Dings hier.
YouTube-Dislikes-Add-on.
Return YouTube-Dislikes brauche ich da noch.
Ja.
Install.
Chrome.
Add.
Extension.
Aha! Aha!
Siehst du mal, da sieht man, dass Dislikes doch nicht so unsinnig sind.
Also, was willst du uns sagen?
Okay.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Clean Code.
Wichtig ist, fehlerfreier Code.
Dann ist es nämlich egal, ob er clean ist.
Dann braucht man nie wieder ihn anfassen,
weil er geht ja einfach.
Einfach, einfach 100% fehlerfrei programmieren.
Brauchst keine Tests.
Du brauchst keine Doku.
Du musst ihn nie wieder anfassen,
weil er geht einfach.
Leute, einfach
just for hand.
Keine Fehler programmieren.
Ich sag's so oft, es kann so einfach sein, aber keiner macht's.
And that name is accompanied by a long list of rules
that tell you what you should do in order for your code to be clean.
Now, there is no benchmark for this.
You cannot actually run something and have it tell you how clean your code is.
But there are fairly descriptive rules that tell you what you should be doing.
Aha.
Now, a large...
Naja, also ganz ehrlich, das unterscheidet sich von...
von Sprache zu Sprache, wie was hübsch aussieht und ja, es gibt sicherlich so ein paar allgemeingültige Sachen wie zum Beispiel Variablen sinnvoll benennen oder nicht so viel Magic alles inline schreiben, sondern es auch mal zwischendrin eine Variable zuweisen, dass man jetzt weiß, was dieser Wert bedeuten soll und so, ja, gibt schon so ein paar allgemeingültige Sachen, aber es variiert halt auch stark von Sprache zu Sprache.
...don't actually affect the right...
...run time of the code that you write, especially not if it's compiled.
And so, there is really no way to objectively assess whether these clean code ideas are good or bad.
And we don't necessarily have to, because they're fairly arbitrary at that.
Der ist ziemlich schlecht aufgelöst für 1080p, oder?
However, there are several aspects of clean code, in fact some of the most important ones that are stated,
are things we could objectively measure, because they do affect the run time of the code.
...run time of the program that you are writing.
Those are, if you go look at a list and pull out the ones that would actually carry through to the code...
Um was geht es jetzt eigentlich genau?
Okay, okay, er zeigt gleich Beispiele, was er will.
...and run on the end user's machine.
There are things like polymorphism...
Oh, das ist geil!
Das finde ich cool!
Mit diesem Draufschreiben.
Wie macht er das denn?
Der schreibt das irgendwo hin, und das ist ja Post-Process drüber.
Glasscheibe, aber Leute, wenn es eine Glasscheibe wäre, da könnten wir es doch nicht richtig lesen.
Da wäre es doch falsch rum.
Oder er spiegelt nachträglich das gesamte Video inklusive ihm selbst.
Aber dann wäre der Aufdruck hier falsch.
Oder sein Arm wäre auf der falschen Seite.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, wie er das gemacht hat.
Also ich gehe davon aus, der schreibt das, und dann wird das Post-Processing-mäßig...
...nochmal overlaid, oder so.
Nee, Leute, ich weiß, wie er das macht.
Guck mal, der schreibt wirklich auf eine Tafel.
Man sieht das hier auch wackeln.
Guck mal, der schreibt auf die Tafel, und der capturert irgendwie die Tafel.
Und das overlaid er dann.
Weil er ist ja auch eindeutig...
Weil er ist eindeutig dahinter.
Er hat ein Video dazu gemacht.
Echt? Okay, das interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Den Namen von ihm mal.
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich, wie er das gemacht hat.
So those are two things you can easily act on.
Always use polymorphism if you can.
Get rid of if and switch statements.
Hä?
Von was spricht er überhaupt?
Das ergibt doch jetzt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Was?
Okay, ich komme überhaupt nicht...
Was will er...
Was will er uns denn jetzt überhaupt sagen?
Also was ist an einem if und einem switch statement jetzt schlecht?
Okay, vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht das, was er uns sagen will, aber...
Ich verstehe gar nicht, was er mir mitteilen möchte.
Number two is no internals for things.
You should never know the internals of something you're working on.
So for example, if you write a function that does something,
it should always call like a polymorphic function in an object or something,
something like that.
And it should never like look into the object to see what's actually in there
or what kind of object it is.
It should never know what like the internals of that thing are, ever.
Na gut, wenn man das objektorientiert sieht,
dann sollte das Objekt so gekapselt sein, dass es transparent funktioniert, ja.
Ich meine, wenn ich irgendein Objekt habe
und das nur mit irgendwelcher reflection magic,
wo ich um drei Ecken rausbekomme,
wie der interne State ist, ordentlich benutzen kann,
dann hat der Typ, der das erstellt hat, irgendwie Mist gebaut, oder?
Okay, ich habe...
Wir kommen noch dahinter, was er will, ja.
Functions should be small.
Da würde ich sagen, es kommt drauf an.
Ja, prinzipiell ist es schon sinnvoll, wenn das übersichtlich ist,
aber ich finde, es macht auch keinen Sinn,
also das kann man halt wieder so pauschal nicht sagen,
ich finde, es macht aber auch keinen Sinn,
einfach nur, damit das eingehalten wird,
auch bei was Komplexerem,
alles aufzusplitten nochmal,
wenn du das Aufgesplittete nur an dieser einen Stelle brauchst.
Also, wenn ich jetzt was habe,
wenn ich halt ein bisschen komplizierteren Sachverhalt habe, so,
und es sind am Ende dann irgendwie 180 Zeilen oder sowas,
ist es halt die Frage, wie sinnvoll es ist,
das aufzusplitten in unterschiedliche Funktionen,
wenn ich die genau nur einmalig aufrufe.
Also, warum sollte ich Unterfunktionen machen,
wenn ich die jeweils nur einmal an der einen Stelle aufrufe?
Da kann ich es wahrscheinlich auch alles untereinander schreiben
und dann muss jemand, der verstehen will,
wie es funktioniert,
nicht an 18 verschiedenen Stellen gucken.
Also, das hängt halt davon,
das hängt wirklich ganz entscheidend davon ab, was man machen will.
Functions should do one thing.
Es geht darum, dass eine Funktion nur ein Ding tut.
Ja gut, aber das Ding kann halt komplex sein, ja.
Now, one thing is never really defined in any particular way
and I don't really think that's all that actionable,
but it is kind of a general rule of thumb.
You could see, affecting how you structure your code,
it's sort of taken together with this,
that you're trying to reduce a function maybe...
Was ein Ding ist, ja, eine Aufgabe sollte die,
also, ist damit gemeint.
Also, soll das jetzt keine Funktion haben,
die zum Beispiel irgendwie einen Input entgegennimmt,
diesen Input umwandelt, validiert
und gleichzeitig hochlädt oder sowas in der Richtung.
Sondern du machst eine Validate-Funktion,
du machst eine Upload-Funktion
und du machst eine Input-Transformations-Funktion zum Beispiel.
Wobei man sich da auch drüber streiten kann,
aber ehrlich gesagt,
wenn die Dinger irgendwie unmittelbar zusammengehören
und auch nur an einer Stelle gebraucht werden,
dann macht es vielleicht doch Sinn,
das in irgendwie so eine Do-Everything-Funktion zu machen.
Wenn ich genau diesen einen Fall habe
und den nur an dieser einen Stelle brauche
und dort eben was als Input bekomme,
das irgendwie transformieren will und dann hochladen will,
kann man das, denke ich,
durchaus am Stück schreiben,
anstatt dass ich dann irgendwie
an fünf, sechs verschiedenen Stellen nachgucken muss.
Es kommt drauf an, was es ist.
Kann man so pauschal gar nicht sagen.
Dry.
Ich weiß, ich mache zu viel Pause,
aber mir fällt immer dazu ein,
dass ich heute nicht mehr in der Påle bin,
weil mir zu wenig Zeit natürlich von den Leuten versungen wird.
Ich weiß, dass ich es lange weggezogen habe,
aber ich weiß, dass ich mich jetzt nicht mehr mehr durch die Zeit verletzt.
Ich weiß, dass ich mich bis jetzt sehr gut verletzen muss.
Ich weiß, dass ich mich noch bereits
in etwas mehreren Spielen bewirkt habe.
Ich weiß, dass ich mich noch besser verstehen kann.
Ich weiß, dass ich viel besser bin,
und der hat die Zeit umgekehrt.
Und ich weiß, dass ich auch immer viel weniger
mit dem Thema liege.
Aber ich weiß, dass ich immer wieder
etwas besser durch die Szene bringen kann.
Weil ich andem Tier in meinem Bewegungszug
halt noch etwas mehr teilnehmen kann.
Ich weiß, dass ich bei diesem Thema
noch ein bisschen mehr drin war,
seinem Talk erzählt, so auch
undurchsichtige
Funktionen und solche Geschichten und dann hat er
das Publikum gefragt,
ja was meint ihr denn, ab wann sind
für mich Funktionen zu lang?
Und das Publikum denkt
sich halt so, ja alter, keine Ahnung,
erzählt es uns halt. Und dann meinte der Typ
in diesem Talk halt, mehr als
eine Zeile.
Und da dachte
ich mir so halt, alter, wie
kompliziert möchtest du deinen Kram
bitteschön machen?
Wie kompliziert und aufgesplittet
möchtest du deinen Kram machen, wenn alles nur
nicht länger als eine Zeile sein darf?
Er listet
gerade Clean-Code-Regeln auf.
Ist es eine Clean-Code-Regel,
man sollte auf Ifs und Switches
verzichten?
Ich meine,
das hier unten
macht ja alles
so pauschal
zwar Sinn, aber man muss sich sie immer
im jeweiligen Kontext angucken.
Ah, du sollst nicht
jetzt verstehe ich, was
das Erste meint.
Du hast recht, EasyLight.
Du sollst nicht über Typen
switchen, das ist damit gemeint.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Also sprich, man soll
jetzt nicht Object
bekommen und dann gucken,
if Object ist
String, if Object ist
Auto, if Object ist
Printer, if Object
ist Smartphone oder sowas,
sondern man bekommt
ein Base-Object oder was auch immer,
ein vererbtes Object, wo ich dann
das drauf aufrufen kann, ohne dass ich
eben explizit
den Typ checken muss. Das meint er.
Das meint er.
Das würde ich tatsächlich auch
pauschal wieder, würde ich sagen,
ist das eine gute Idee.
Es gibt immer Ausnahmen.
Es gibt immer Ausnahmen,
wo es doch Sinn macht.
C++?
Muss es ausgerechnet
C++ sein?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Soll ich euch mal was dazu erzählen?
Das ist eine sehr,
dass da schon seit
Jahrzehnten eine
sehr
philosophische Debatte
drüber geführt wird.
Zum Beispiel,
Meine Frage an euch, Chat. Ich denke mal, viele von euch kennen das.
Mal angenommen, bleiben wir mal bei Shape.
Ihr habt eine Base Class Shape.
Und ihr wollt jetzt eine Klasse machen für Ellipse oder sagen wir für Rechteck und für Quadrat.
Oder für Kreis oder Ellipse.
Leitet ihr Ellipse von Kreis ab oder Kreis von Ellipse?
Oder auch Rechteck von Quadrat oder Quadrat von Rechteck?
Da gibt es schon seit Jahrzehnten sehr philosophische Debatten drüber.
Ja, das geht schon in die...
So würde ich es tatsächlich auch machen.
Man sieht, der Chat ist sich da auch nicht ganz einig.
Das ist...
Ja, wobei das halt vererbungstechnisch auch schwierig ist.
Also zum Beispiel...
Also warum es...
Da gibt es übrigens...
Also wer das sich im Detail angucken will hier.
Ich habe gerade euch mal den Wikipedia-Artikel rausgesucht.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht zusammen an.
Aber wie gesagt, also das Problem wird schon relativ lange diskutiert.
Und da gibt es verschiedenste Lösungsansätze.
Du hast zum Beispiel das Problem, dass du bei einem Rechteck kannst du quasi so die Höhe und die Breite...
setzen.
Das macht...
bei einem Quadrat keinen Sinn.
Weil bei einem Quadrat ist die Höhe und die Breite immer gleich.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt ein...
Quadrat ableitest...
von deiner Rechteck-Klasse...
kannst du auf einmal bei deinem Quadrat...
Höhe und Breite setzen, was ja keinen Sinn macht.
Oder halt auch hier beim Kreis, da ist es glaube ich...
irgendwie Durchmesser und sowas in der Richtung.
Das wird seit Jahrzehnten schon lange diskutiert.
Es gibt sogar Programmiersprachen.
Da ist tatsächlich so, dass Rechteck von Quadrat abgeleitet ist.
Das meiste sind irgendwelche super esoterischen Dinger, wo einer zeigen wollte, dass das auch geht.
Also die haben dann Rechteck von Quadrat abgeleitet.
Weil du halt ein...
aus Programmiertechnik...
technischer Sicht...
erweiterst du ja quasi die Funktion...
von einem...
Quadrat, so mit dem Rechteck.
Nämlich, dass du...
noch Höhe und Breite unabhängig voneinander setzen kannst.
Mathematisch gesehen ist es natürlich bescheuert zu sagen...
dass jedes Rechteck ein Quadrat ist.
Das ja, das Linux-Desktops.
Ja, das kommt höchstens mal bei WSL.
Also es ist sinnvoll...
einfach Oberklasse-Viereck erstellen.
Viereck ist dann für dich auch was, was kein Rechteck ist, was auch alles sein kann, tja.
Also am besten ist wahrscheinlich, man nimmt Shape als Base für beides und macht es dann unabhängig voneinander.
Hier ist... das ist ja auch... im Prinzip gibt es ja hier auch schon die Erklärung zu.
Also was das Problem ist.
So, aber was in einer typischen Klassenhierarchie zur Implementierung der Grafik so könnte von einer Basisklasse...
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla.
So die Klasse Ellipse abgeleitet werden und von diesen wiederum die Klasse Kreis.
Das ist ja das, was ich gesagt habe, dass du...
Das wäre das mathematische, dass du Kreis von Ellipse ableitest.
Achso, na okay, die beschreiben das hier ein bisschen anders.
Zeichne...
Ja.
Genau, das ist das Beispiel, was ich meine, ja.
Du kannst... du hast jetzt bei Ellipse hast du Methoden Skaliere X, Skaliere Y.
Das macht aber bei einem Kreis keinen Sinn.
Weil du kannst einen Kreis ja nicht wirklich...
X skalieren und Y... du kannst es ja immer nur gleich machen.
Das heißt eigentlich mathematisch gesehen ist es richtig, dass Kreis von Ellipse erbt.
Allerdings aus objektorientierter Sicht ist es blödsinnig.
Weil ja eigentlich Ellipse eine Erweiterung von Kreis ist.
Also Kreis hätte die Methode Skaliere.
Weil du brauchst beim Kreis Skaliere X, Skaliere Y nicht.
Sondern einfach nur Scale.
Und dann... in beide Richtungen.
Und dann müsstest du logischerweise Ellipse von Kreis...
eigentlich ableiten.
Weil das du zusätzlich zu skalieren in beide Richtungen gleichzeitig unabhängig voneinander skalieren kannst.
Was dann aber wiederum ein Widerspruch ist, weil du dann sagen würdest, ja okay...
dass jede Ellipse ein Kreis ist, was auch wieder keinen Sinn ergibt.
Das gleiche Problem gibt es auch mit Quadrat und Rechteck, genau.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt, da gibt es schon seit Jahrzehnten Diskussionen darüber, wie es jetzt eigentlich richtig ist.
Und am besten ist, finde ich...
ähm...
man umgeht das Problem komplett indem man sowohl Kreis als auch Ellipse von grafisches Element ableitet.
Also ich vermute, dass es...
Ups, wo sind wir denn hier?
Äh...
Warum hat sich das denn jetzt resetet?
...they are actually fairly specific about how any particular piece of code should be created in order for it to be quote-on-quote clean.
Ok. Clean.
Also da sieht man, das geht gar nicht so ohne weiteres alles, ja?
Weißt du, wann für mich der Code clean ist?
Wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass es ein sehr unspezifisches, kann man nicht genau,
wenn ich ein gutes Gefühl habe, wenn ich das durchlese und denke, ja, das versteht man gut.
Fertig, dann ist clean genug.
Also der Fehler ist schon mal, clean code examples sich in C++ anzugucken.
Weil es ist so ziemlich einfach.
Alles clean, bloß nicht C++.
Ja, okay.
Okay, aber ich kann der Sache immer nicht genau folgen, wo er jetzt eigentlich drauf raus will.
Also, okay, er möchte uns in dem Video zeigen, dass wenn man es quasi clean macht, das Kack-Performance ist.
Okay.
Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt in C++...
In C++ eh schon nicht mal, sondern nicht clean.
Weil ich jetzt überhaupt nicht checken würde, wozu gehört dann jetzt zum Beispiel...
Ach nee, das ist eine Funktion losgelöst von den Klassen oben.
Okay.
Ich spule gleich mal ein bisschen vor.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wenn ich das hier schon sehe, da kommen jetzt gleich wieder die Leute aus den Löchern und sagen, das ist aber nicht modern C++.
Das geht nicht.
Das muss ein shared pointer of Dingsbums, of shape, of shape base sein.
Sonst ist ja, das ist ja nicht so möglich, ne.
Das ist sogar ein Array, oder?
Das ist ein shared pointer of vector of shape.
Das muss ein shared pointer of vector of shape sein.
Alles klar, C++.
Das würde den Compiler verwirren.
So, hier sind wir.
Wir schaffen einen Akkumulator.
Wir loopen alle Formen in dem Array, den wir gegeben haben.
Wir nennen die Funktion des Areas und wir zurück.
Nun, ihr werdet bemerken, dass das Arrays von Pointers sein müssen, weil wir keine Ahnung haben, wie groß diese Formen sind.
Also, ohne dass wir die Länge der Formen ausprobieren und einen Skip-Prozess nutzen, um sie durch zu gehen, müssen wir nur die Pointer schauen, um zu finden, wo die Formen tatsächlich sind.
Also, ohne dass wir die Länge der Formen ausprobieren und einen Skip-Prozess nutzen, müssen wir nur die Pointer schauen, um zu finden, wo die Formen tatsächlich sind.
Also, ohne dass wir die Länge der Formen ausprobieren und einen Skip-Prozess nutzen, um zu finden, wo die Formen tatsächlich sind.
Also, wenn man sie durch zu gehen, muss man einen Skript verfolgen.
Das ist der Spektrum.
failed
Also, wenn manと思いますást Blesses vorstellt,哦
Okay, alles klar.
okay, alles klar.
So.
Okay, alles klar.
gut
Leute, da gehen noch die Rust-Leute auf HackerNews bestimmt steil,
die erzählen uns dann selbstverständlich, dass das in Rust alles so viel geiler ist.
So, das ist gefundenes Fressen für die Rust Task Force auf Hacker News.
Da gehen die richtig steil drauf.
Was?
Nur, nur, nur, dass ich das jetzt ungefähr halbwegs checke, was ich da überhaupt sehe.
Ich bin bei der...
Okay.
Der hat einmal einen Benchmark, wo diese Funktionen einmal ausgeführt werden und dann wo die tausendmal
ausgeführt werden.
So, dann hat er eine Funktion, die irgendwie alles der Reihe nach macht und dann hat er
was, wo vier Stück quasi pro Schleifendurchlauf gemacht werden, so in der Hoffnung, dass das
mit CPU, Inline Caching oder wie auch immer schneller ist oder oder was ist da...
Weil das ist ja nicht Multisignal.
Es ist nicht Threaded, das Ganze.
Es ist passiert halt nur in einer Schleife.
Okay.
Also man könnte...
Man könnte es wahrscheinlich auch so machen wie bei Xenon 2 oder so, oder wenn es etwas
der Branche Predikter geben würde, wir würden hier etwas verbessern.
Was wir von den Ergebnissen sehen können, ist, dass es hier nicht so viel Unterschied
gibt.
Es sind ungefähr 35 Kreuzeilungen, um das Ding zu machen.
Vielleicht geht es etwas mehr hin zu 34, manchmal, wenn man wirklich glücklich ist.
Das ist also die clean version des Codes.
Es dauert etwa 35 Kreuzeilungen.
Man könnte, man könnte noch mal die ganze Technik wiederholen, aber das geht nicht so gut.
Man könnte auch an der Stelle einfach auf ganzen Vererbungskram scheißen und ein Interface machen, I-Area oder irgendwie sowas, und überhaupt keinen großartigen Vererbungs-Base-Class-Stells machen.
So here I've written the exact same code, but instead of writing it in the polymorphism way using C++ classes and virtual functions,
I've written it using a standard enum and then just a shape type that effectively just unions them.
So even if something didn't have a height, for example, because it's only one parameter, well, it has one now, because we've done this the old-fashioned way.
Then we say instead of getting the area from a virtual function, you're going to get it from a switch statement,
exactly the thing that a clean code lecture would tell you never ever do.
And what we would do here is we'd say switch on the type, and depending on which,
of the types we have, we will go ahead and compute the exact same thing that we were computing
in the virtual function for the derived class of that type.
Now we have effectively the exact same code.
Here's the switch statement version of the exact same thing that we saw before for the V-Table version.
Because it doesn't have to wonder about what kind of types might be derived from a base class.
It can see everything that's in this code.
So the width and performance between the one that has,
we can just use a V-Table because it's using C++ classes and one that just can use.
Oh, es ist viel schneller, Pogu.
We can look at the difference between the two, and I'll skip the video here so you don't have to wait for the testing to happen.
And when we look at the results, what you can see is really rather remarkable.
Just that one change.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das zweite Beispiel finde ich auch viel einfacher lesbar.
An der Stelle.
Also, ich habe eh den Eindruck, dass die letzten Jahre über es den Trend gibt,
es nicht mehr so sehr zu übertreiben, was Objektorientierung angeht.
Selbst in Sprachen wie C-Sharp, die mal ursprünglich als Microsoft-Java-Abklatsch gestartet sind,
die quasi komplett auf Objektorientierung gesetzt haben,
dass man schon sieht, auch bei JavaScript sieht man es,
dass der Trend schon ein bisschen dahin geht,
wobei JavaScript macht jetzt tatsächlich das Gegenteil,
die fangen jetzt mit Class-Syntax erst richtig an,
dass der Trend ein bisschen dahin geht, dass man sich so aus der funktionalen Ecke bedient.
Dass man auch teilweise mehr Interfaces benutzt,
dass man mehr anonyme Funktionen als Parameter benutzt.
Also zum Beispiel, dass man jetzt nicht sagt, hier Array.Filter
und ich brauche jetzt hier eine Funktion, die ich benutze,
und ich brauche dann irgendwie ein Array-Filter-Base-Class,
sondern ich mache dann anonyme Funktionen rein, wie gefiltert werden soll und gut ist.
Und ich finde, der Trend geht ein bisschen dahin, dass es nicht mehr ganz so schlimm ist.
Die haben es früher ziemlich übertrieben, das stimmt,
aber mittlerweile sieht man auch, dass sie an ganz vielen Stellen,
anstatt jetzt riesen Class von Class von Class abgeladen haben,
abgeleitet benutzen, dass die ganz gerne auch die Dinger kombinieren zusammen.
Mit irgendwelchen Bildern und hast du nicht gesehen.
Also ich finde, das sieht man die letzten Jahre auch in C-Sharp.
Eigentlich in C-Sharp ganz gut, weil die letzten C-Sharp-Versionen haben vieles übernommen,
was man vorher aus eher funktionaler Ecke gekannt hat.
Ordentliche Lambda-Syntax gibt es schon lange.
Seit den letzten paar Versionen wird verstärkt auf...
auf so Dinger gesetzt, wie Pattern Matching zum Beispiel und solche Geschichten.
Das gab es ja früher nicht.
Man kann sich bestimmt drüber schreiten,
wie schön da manches implementiert ist, weil manches finde ich auch nicht gerade super griffig zu bedienen.
Aber den Einfluss von so funktionalen Sprachen kann man, denke ich, auch bei C-Sharp jetzt nicht mehr übersehen.
Was hältst du von WPF?
Ehrlich gesagt nix.
WPF ist Windows-only.
Also es hängt wie immer davon ab, was man machen will.
Aber WPF ist Windows-only und ist auch nicht sonderlich modern.
Es ist nur minimal moderner als Windows Forms.
Es kann auch nicht wirklich aus heutigen Gesichtspunkten so viel mehr, was man heute brauchen würde im Vergleich zu Windows Forms.
Ich meine natürlich, WPF hatte riesen neues Rendering-Background auf DirectX.
Das war schon viel, aber es ist trotzdem heute hoffnungslos veraltet.
Du hast in WPF-Anwendungen beispielsweise Textelemente, die noch nicht mal Emoji-Support haben.
Also kannst du noch nicht mal Color-Emojis drin verwenden, weil eben das der uralte Front-Renderer ist, der da drin benutzt wird.
Und...
Schrift-Anti-Alasings...
Deswegen hat in WPF auch noch nie richtig gut funktioniert, seit Anfang an bis heute.
Also nee, WPF finde ich nicht so nice.
Microsoft selbst hat ja auch keinen Bock mehr auf WPF.
Die machen jetzt MAUI, beziehungsweise unter Windows ist es da unten drunter WinUI.
Allerdings muss ich ehrlich sagen, MAUI ist auch nicht so mein Fall.
MAUI ist quasi Xamarin 2.0 und das hat mir schon nicht gefallen.
Wenn ich in .NET ein Cross-Plattform-UI machen müsste heutzutage...
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich das hier probieren.
Habe ich mir übrigens aufgeschrieben, wollte ich mir demnächst auch mal im Stream angucken.
Läuft unter Mac-Linux-Windows.
Und ich glaube, damit würde ich glücklicher werden als MAUI.
So wirklich geil finde ich aber XML-Zeug immer noch nett, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Also, ich werde damit wahrscheinlich nicht wab werden.
Warum es auch unbedingt XML sein musste, ich weiß nicht.
Klar kann man jetzt sagen, HTML ist ja im Prinzip auch XML.
Es ist halt doof, dass das Beste, was es gibt für Cross-Plattformen, tatsächlich so ein Scheiß wie Elektron ist.
Sackt halt ein bisschen.
Mal gucken, wann Flutter Desktop richtig gut funktioniert.
Der Fokus...
Der Fokus bei Flutter liegt ja eindeutig eher auf Mobile.
Ja, Qt ist wirklich gut.
Also Qt gefällt mir von den ganzen Cross-Plattform-Frameworks, wenn es wirklich Native sein soll.
Am besten allerdings ist es halt C++.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt auch gute Python-Bindings.
Aber am Ende kommst du da irgendwie bei C++ raus.
Ja, also leider ist Native Desktop-UI-Entwicklung...
Scheiße.
Ich glaube, anders kann man das nicht sagen.
Was meint ihr denn, warum so viele Anwendungen heutzutage schlicht und ergreifend einfach in Desktop-Fenster-gerappte Browser-Anwendungen sind?
Aus dem Grund.
Und da ist Microsoft nicht ganz unschuldig dran.
Weil Microsoft hat es die letzten 15 Jahre über mega verkackt.
Die haben erst angefangen mit ihrem komischen JavaScript-basiertem Zeug für Windows 8.
Und UWP und dann UWP 2.0.
Und dann irgendwann...
Ach, UWP ist doch kacke.
Wir machen WinUI, aber wir machen WinUI mit allen Nachteilen von UWP.
Und jetzt gibt es endlich WinUI 3, aber das ist auch noch nicht richtig fertig, wenn es Unpackaged-Applications...
Es ist für ein Arsch.
Also Microsoft hat es da richtig verkackt.
Aber selbst nicht Cross-Plattform.
Selbst Windows-Only gibt es ja nichts Gescheites.
Das ist ja das Dumme.
Das ist einfach nur Schrott, was Microsoft die letzten Jahre über veranstaltet hat.
Also wahrscheinlich ist das Beste wirklich entweder Qt oder Elektron.
So blöd es klingt.
Vielleicht in Zukunft Flutter.
Und bei allen anderen Sachen müsste man mal schauen, ob man dann da auch wirklich gut mit klarkommt.
Auch wenn man vielleicht so ein bisschen advancedere Sachen braucht oder so ein paar Edge-Cases hat.
Tauri, das ist doch auch Browser-Krempel.
Nur dass es eben kein extra Chrome mitbringt.
Sondern die jeweilige Betriebssystem-Plattform nimmt.
Da hast du dann aber wahrscheinlich wieder andere Probleme.
Mac-Only ist gut.
Ja, ich habe...
Okay, hören, sagen, was ich lese.
Ich entwickle keine Mac-Anwendung.
Aber was das angeht, kann man wohl Apple da nichts vorwerfen.
Das ist seit Jahren wohl ganz gut.
Native Mac- und iOS-Entwicklung.
Maui geht doch auch Native.
Ja, aber Maui ist Kacke.
Maui ist ja quasi nur ein Rapper, wenn du es so willst.
Maui nimmt immer das, was Microsoft als die beste Technologie für die jeweilige Plattform auserkoren hat.
Also Maui nimmt unten drunter unter Windows,
wahrscheinlich mit, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass es mittlerweile so ist.
WinUI.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du noch irgendeinen Legacy-UWP-Mode aktivieren.
Unter Linux ist es GTK, wobei das nicht offiziell ist.
Maui unterstützt nämlich gar kein Linux offiziell.
Und unter Mac ist es halt...
Cocoa ist es, glaube ich, oder?
Wie heißt das Zeug unter Mac für GUI-Anwendungen?
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt von ihm nochmal belehren, warum das alles viel besser ist.
Du bekommst sofort was, was effektiv eine 1.5x-Performance ist.
Also, das sind quasi 50% schneller oder sowas, hä?
...doing anything other than removing all of that extraneous stuff that's required to have C++-Polymorphism.
So by violating this rule of clean code, which is one of the central tenets,
we were able to drop down to 24 cycles per shape,
which means that the clean code version that follows rule number one is 1.5 times slower, roughly.
This means that if you were to...
Und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Dass die Nicht-Clean-Code-Variante sogar noch für mich in dem Fall besser zu lesen ist.
Deswegen würde ich auch gar nicht so weit gehen und sagen, das erste ist unbedingt die Clean-Code-Variante.
Also wenn es darum geht, dass es gut lesbar ist, finde ich die zweite Variante in dem Fall viel angenehmer.
...to put that in hardware terms, it would be like taking a iPhone 14 Pro Max
and reducing...
...and reducing it down to an iPhone 11 Pro Max.
It's about three or four years of hardware evolution.
Erased, because somebody told you to use Polymorphism instead of switch statements.
But we're only just getting started.
What if, instead of following these four rules and just breaking this one,
we also broke number two, meaning let's see about knowing what if our functions could use knowledge
of what they were actually operating on to make themselves more efficient in aggregate.
If you look back at the get-area-switch-statement, one of the things that you can see is really
these are all computing the exact same function, just with a different coefficient.
They're all going to do something like width times height or width times width,
and then they're going to multiply by half in the case of a triangle or pi in the case of a circle.
Something like this.
Now, one of the reasons that I think switch statements are great is because they actually show you.
It's really easy to pull out common patterns when you look at them put together by function rather than by class.
By contrast, if you were to look back at the class version, you would probably never notice this pattern,
because each of these would probably...
Ja, die class version ist auch gerade in C++, aber allgemein total pepega, also wozu?
...put in a different file, and you would never really see that there was quite a bit of similarity between them.
So architecturally, I generally disagree with that.
By the way, man sieht hier übrigens eine schöne C++-Besonderheit.
An der Stelle.
Man sieht hier irgendwo eine schöne C++-Besonderheit.
Äh, nee, oder?
Nee, doch nicht. Ich hab mich verguckt.
Oder doch?
Ah, nee.
...never noticed this pattern, because each of these would probably be put in a different file,
and you would never really see that there was quite a bit of similarity between them.
So architecturally, I generally disagree with that structure anyway, but that's kind of beside the point.
The point is, we can simplify this quite a bit.
And remember, this is not an example that I picked.
This is the example that clean code advocates use.
So I'm not picking an example where you happen to be able to pull out a pattern.
I'm using their example and I can pull out a pattern, because in general this is what happens in code.
So, if we actually look at what we can do here, we can just introduce a simple table
that says what the coefficient is that we actually need to use.
Then we'll make sure that we always stuff the height with the same thing as the width.
Okay.
Okay, das kann man so machen, wobei ich sagen muss, an der Stelle wird es dann schon langsam aber sicher ein bisschen unübersichtlich,
vielleicht, wenn man es so macht.
Ich meine, solange das hier noch oben drüber steht, dann ist das kein großartiges Ding.
Da wird es vielleicht schon ein bisschen schwieriger.
Man könnte an der Stelle vielleicht echt einen Function Call machen, wo das dann innen drin definiert ist.
In der Funktion, nicht hier irgendwie global.
Ja, irgendwie so eine CalcArea-Funktion, wo das dann drinnen steht.
Und das hier würde ich dann auch einer Variable zuweisen.
Also ich würde das hier oben rausholen, irgendwie zuweisen.
Und das dann in der, was weiß ich, war, was ist das hier, war, keine Ahnung, wie man das hier nennen kann.
Okay.
Dann war, blub, gleich das da.
Und dann da unten würde ich dann, blub, mal ShapeWidth, blub, mal ShapeHeight, Height, ja.
Aber, ich meine, da fängt es schon langsam aber sicher an, ein bisschen unübersichtlich zu werden.
Width, so that in cases where we were just using the width twice, it will still work.
That allows us to collapse our switch statement into a single simple equation,
which just looks at a table for the one thing that differs in the operations.
Now.
Now, the two functions that will use this are exactly the same.
We don't have to modify them at all.
The only difference is now we'll use this to get our area instead of the switch statement.
Let's see what happens if we run that version now.
Pass auf, noch schneller.
Massive.
Achtmal schneller.
What you can see here is that by taking advantage of what we know about the actual types that we have,
and by treating the function that we're doing as more important than the types themselves and keeping them opaque,
Huge speeding.
We get a massive speed increase.
Massive.
Now we've gone from something that's merely 1.5 times faster to something that's 10 times faster or more on the exact same problem,
using nothing other than a very simple table-driven calculation,
because it's very easy to observe what the actual patterns are in this code
when we think of them by function rather than by type,
and allow functions to know the internals of what they're working on.
So by actually...
I do believe that with such an exact same value,
I think that as close to 12.10,
nearly as close as thisindahoose is,
every Python programmer would have done so.
He's, you know...
Now not with global variables like these...
He would have created a dictionary...
And then...
Well, he probably would have created a dictionary shapeType to Nummer .
And then he would have looked,
welcher Shape Type kommt da rein und ich finde, das ist eigentlich eine sinnvolle Variante.
Kann man auch so ganz gut lesen.
Also ich finde, man kann meistens sagen, umso kompakter es ist, umso besser kann man es lesen,
wobei das ab einer gewissen Kompaktheit aufhört.
Also wenn man dann anfängt Variablen Namen zu kürzen, nur dass es noch kompakter wird,
wenn man New Lines rausnimmt, nur dass es noch kompakter wird,
wenn man verschiedene Dinger komplizierter macht, nur dass es noch kompakter wird, dann nicht.
Aber in der Regel ist es einfacher, wenn du die Funktionalität in 5 Zeilen packst, als in 30,
weil 30 Zeilen zu überblicken, was passiert da eigentlich schlicht und ergreifend komplizierter ist,
als das, wenn du einfach drauf guckst, okay, hier ist easy, sofort offensichtlich, was passiert.
Und bei dem ganzen Hin- und Hergespringe sonst über 30 Zeilen eher nicht.
Ja.
Ja, eine weitere Sache, man muss halt sagen, ein bisschen doof hier, weil das ist halt auch wieder so eine C++-Geschichte,
oder Low-Level-Geschichte, das hier ist ja wahrscheinlich nur so eine Art Array,
weil es hier auch Shape-Count ist, also sprich in Type, in Shape-Type steht dann eine Nummer drin,
die mit dem Array-Index übereinstimmen muss, dass es funktioniert.
Das würdest du zum Beispiel jetzt in irgendeinem Python-Dictionary, hättest du das einfacher,
dann würdest du nämlich wirklich ein Dictionary,
ein Dictionary machen, Shape-Type zur Nummer.
Ja gut, das wäre dann nicht so schnell, weil ein Array ist immer noch das Schnellste, was es gibt.
Ähm, na gut.
12,10.
Until clean code happened.
Also wie gesagt, für mich ist es clean, wenn es gut lesbar ist,
und der Sinn schnell erkennbar ist.
Das ist für mich, ob das dann irgendwelchen super krassen Clean-Code-Guidelines folgt oder so,
wenn es kompakt ist, gut zu verstehen ist, ist das für mich clean genug.
Und wir wissen ja, Hauptsache es muss fehlerfrei sein.
Fehlerfrei, just fehlerfrei programmieren.
Vorher.
Jetzt, das Wichtigste daran zu erinnern ist,
10x ist ein so riesiger Leistungsaufwand,
dass es nicht wirklich möglich ist, es in den iPhone-Terms zu bezeichnen.
Denn die iPhone-Benchmarks gehen nicht weit zurück.
Wenn ich all die Weile zurückgehen würde zu den iPhone 6,
was wir Benchmarks dafür haben, wenn du dir die gemeinsamen Benchmark-Sites anschaust,
sind es nur drei mal...
Ist Punkt 2 nicht Information-Hiding?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung wollte er uns glaube ich damit sagen.
Dass er jetzt direkt quasi...
Informationen benutzt aus dem Typ als Index für das Array, anstatt dass der Typ das irgendwie
selber macht.
Weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen kann, es kommt ja auf den Anwendungsfall an, es gibt
ja, es gibt ja...
Also, bei Games, okay, ja, aber es gibt ja durchaus Anwendungsfälle, da ist es nicht
so wichtig, ob das jetzt in 40 Nanosekunden oder in 400 Nanosekunden durch ist.
Je nachdem, was da ist.
Dazu kommt allerdings, wo ich eben tatsächlich recht geben würde, nicht wirklich recht geben
würde, sondern ich finde die letzten beiden Beispiele aber sogar besser als die ursprünglichen
Clean-Code-Beispiele, weil sie einfach einfacher, weil sie für mich cleaner aussehen und besser
zu lesen sind.
Doing the simplest possible operation, right?
I mean, we are doing these two things by default, because all we're doing is computing the area
and it'd be very difficult to figure out how you could make a large function out of computing
the area, because it's just like a multiplication or two.
What if we add one more aspect to our problem?
Just one?
So that we can follow these two rules of Clean-Code and see how much worse the Clean-Code gets...
Chet, da habt ihr recht, da habt ihr recht, dass früher teilweise auch deutlich mehr
optimiert wurde und auf Kleinigkeiten geachtet wurde.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist Dings hier, Rollercoaster Tycoon.
Das erste, das hier, das ist zum größten Teil von Hand in Assembler programmiert.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Da musst du absolut giga-fivehead sein, um sowas in Assembler zu bauen.
Das war zum größten Teil handoptimiert.
Also das Rendering und alles weiß ich nicht genau, ja?
Aber das unter der Haube ist handoptimiertes Assembler.
Ja, das ist richtig krass.
Also der ist richtig fivehead.
Das kannst du natürlich bei vielen, das stimmt schon, das kannst du bei vielen Games heute
in der Art und Weise natürlich nicht machen.
Du kannst jetzt nicht anfangen, bei irgendeinem Aktivismus...
Im aktuellen AAA-Game in Unreal, da im großen Stil handoptimiertes Assembler,
weil da wirst du ja nicht fertig.
An manchen Stellen ist das sicherlich immer noch sinnvoll.
Wenn du irgendwas hast, was jeden, jedes Bild, oder es muss ja nicht mal jedes Bild sein,
heute passieren ja durchaus Sachen nicht nur im Bildrhythmus, also quasi, was bei jedem
Durchlauf, bei jedem Dings, jedes Mal benutzt wird.
Ähm, und du rufst das so auf.
Du rufst das so oft auf, dann macht das durchaus heute noch Sinn, denke ich mal.
Auch wenn du spielen in Unreal-Programm ist, irgendwelche handoptimierten Assembler-Sachen zu bauen, ja.
Ja, in Unreal intern ist, denke ich, jede Menge, tatsächlich jede Menge optimiertes Assembler-Zeug drin.
War Unreal nicht den Clean-Code?
Ich glaube, wir wollen intern gar nicht wissen, wie Unreal aussieht.
Da schlummern bestimmt auch sehr abartige Dinger drin.
Okay, pass auf, was kommt als nächstes?
100% Performance-Increase.
Woher kommt dieses Clean-Code?
Ja, das sind Regeln, die er hier aufgreift, die so im Internet rumschwirren als, das sind
die offiziellen Beispiele wohl davon, so sieht Clean-Code aus und das greift er hier auf.
Es gibt ja schon seit einer ganzen Weile so diese, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das offiziell
unter Clean-Code läuft, ja, so diese Sachen mit Solid und so.
Und, ähm, äh, Dry und was hast du denn sonst noch alles drinne?
Ja, und so ein paar dieser Punkte, die er am Anfang zeigt.
Gibt es dafür eine Norm?
Nee, ich glaube, eine Norm nicht, aber so ein paar mehr oder weniger offizielle, halboffizielle
Guidelines.
Nee, das ist wieder was anderes.
Bei, das ist wieder was anderes.
Bei denen geht es ums Implementieren von, ähm, oft, oft gebrauchten,
äh, Mustern, Patterns, ja, so Subscriber zum Beispiel, so wie mit Twitch Prime, Subscriber-Pattern,
nee, Observer-Pattern, heißt ja nicht Subscriber, Observer-Pattern und, und Factories und sowas,
da geht's darum.
Ähm, da geht's nicht unbedingt um Clean-Code.
... that we had before, but this time we've added one more virtual function, which gets
us a corner count.
In other words, a rectangle has four corners, a triangle has three, a circle has none.
Okay.
I'm then going to compute, instead of the total area, I'm gonna compute the total area,
but weighted by one over one plus the number of corners.
There's no reason for this, I just needed something to compute that was as close as
possible to the original example that they gave, but which included a second property
that wasn't found in the original.
Now, when we're gonna do this in...
Okay, huge speed increase kommt jetzt wieder.
... of course we call corner count an area as...
Okay, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommen wir aber so langsam.
... in die Region, wo ich sag, jetzt wird's langsam ein bisschen schwierig lesbar.
... also, jetzt, jetzt fällt's mir schon ein bisschen schwer, hier durchzublicken, was
es da eigentlich geht, ja.
Ähm, mal ne blöde Frage, warum rechnet er dann hier plus eins?
Achso, weil er null Komma irgendwas dann raus haben will, oder?
Eins plus, äh, wahrscheinlich, dass hier nicht null rauskommen kann, oder?
Ist das hier, dass er, dass er null vermeidet?
Ja, ne?
Das ist, dass er null vermeidet, weil wenn hier null rauskommt, dann rechnet er hier
einzeln durch null und es geht kaputt.
... separate virtual functions, and then we compute what we want to compute.
Now, we might even pull this out into yet another function, but what we definitely know
is we cannot fuse these two into one function, because that would not be following the rules
of clean code, which say that everything has to kind of come from the simplest possible
functions and then they compose themselves up, so all we do...
Also, ich finde es sonderlich gut lesbar, ist es jetzt an der Stelle?
Ja, aber nett.
... at best is this, and at worst we would have to pull this into yet another function,
but I'm giving it the benefit out by leaving it this way.
Here's what it would look like if we use the clean code version, both the normal way of
writing it and the one that breaks the loop carrier dependency here, just in case.
If we look at the union version, what you can see is not very much would change, we'd
just add another switch statement that would tell us how many corners there are, and then
we would compute the exact same thing.
So again, the code looks almost identical.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt schon wieder den Faden verloren, was er uns eigentlich genau jetzt sagen will,
also lass mal Benchmark-Ergebnisse gucken.
... the class case versus the switch case, the only difference being change which table
we were using, and done the exact same thing.
Now if we run all of these together, we will be able to see what the differences are now
that we've added a second property.
And again, I'll skip ahead so that you don't have to wait.
Looking at the results now, the case is even worse for quote unquote clean code.
Da hab ich mit gerechnet, dass er zu dem Fazit kommt!
... and our lookup table version is almost 15 times faster!
That's just insane!
Und sie ist einfacher zu lesen!
... and it just gets worse, because the more you use the clean code methodology, the less
a compiler is able to see what you're doing, because everything is behind these virtual
function calls and obfuscation of that kind.
So as a result, it makes it harder and harder for the compiler to see what you're doing.
And of course, you also can't really do your job very well because you can't do things
like pull things out of the tables.
The code just isn't structured that way.
As you can see, making our problem more complicated doesn't benefit the clean code solution.
It actually hurts it.
We've gone from a 10x speed difference to a 15x speed difference.
That's like pushing the hardware all the way back to 2008.
So instead of erasing 12 years of . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . 200, 200, okay, weiter.
Dann jetzt... Ah, den kenne ich, der macht gute Videos.
Der Nick, der macht gute Videos.
Okay.
Mir reicht es ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich gebe ihm da schon in großen Teilen recht.
Einfach blind irgendwelchen Rules, die Leute im Internet aufgestellt haben, zu folgen und dann zu sagen, ah, jetzt ist es clean.
Obwohl es einfach nur bloated as fuck ist.
Muss nicht sein.
Okay, nice.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da Hacker-News zusagt.
893 Comments.
Das dachte ich.
Das dachte ich mir, dass die da nicht so scharf drauf sind.
Okay, das lesen wir uns jetzt nicht durch.
Die haben sich ja wieder hier komplett aus...
Was mich interessiert ist, wenn ich nach Rust suche...
Leute, was meint ihr?
Ich suche jetzt nach Rust.
Wie oft wird Rust auf dieser Seite gefunden?
Moment, Moment.
Load more comments.
Okay.
Wie oft wird Rust gefunden?
Was?
Moment, da fehlt doch jetzt die Hälfte.
Wait a minute.
Ne, ne, ne.
Da stimmt was nicht.
Hacker-News ist wieder...
Ist wieder kacke.
Rust.
Acht...
Ne, Moment.
Vielleicht soll ich ja Rust.
Wie?
Nur, nur, nur zweimal.
Was ist da los?
Siebenmal?
Okay, siebenmal.
Neunmal?
Okay, jetzt kommen sie erst richtig in Fahrt.
Aber in den letzten 15 nicht.
Also irgendwie so 30 mal oder so.
Morgen, morgen.
Nicht jetzt.
Must know terminal commands.
Grab.
Hui!
Advanceder Shit.
So.
Dann machen wir jetzt Schluss, Leute.
Da hatten wir heute ja heute ziemlich 50-50 streamen.
50% Handy gucken, 50% Random Talk.
Gerade reingekommen.
Ja, die letzten trifft immer irgendein, der als letztes reinkommt.
Was?
Track Mania?
Guck ich nicht.
Kein Track Mania.
Alert.
So ist das gut.
Danke für die ganzen...
Die ganzen Saps, Leute.
Ich habe bestimmt wieder die Hälfte übersehen.
Habe ich auch.
Aber ich glaube auch.
Wen haben wir denn hier noch?
Edelknecht und Schicksi.
Danke für den Sub.
Moment.
Sind nur Follows.
Keck Wade.
Wer guckt?
Dann habe ich doch nichts übersehen.
Panda, dich habe ich übersehen.
Dankeschön.
Panda, Doomswap.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich habe gar nichts gesehen.
Okay.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
To you.